[Music]
foreign
oh man we have made it welcome in this
is it March Madness the week's leading
up to it and we are here this is be our
final four live presented by Wendy's so
excited to be here joined by the one the
only Robbie Hummel Purdue and then I've
also been told a pickleball player as
well
not me
Tyler Hansbrough as well Legend in
Chapel Hill ping pong as well my intros
aren't as good as Adam so I apologize
for that he really let it go I'm Ashley
shawnity we're going to be here watching
the game with you uh commenting bringing
on some fun guests doing all the things
if you saw them on Saturday they were
able to watch the two games leading up
to this and now this is it guys this is
for everything man and you talk about
David Goliath's Cinderella Story you got
San Diego State coming in here UConn
who's been here before this has been a
first for SDSU first for many of their
appearances and now you got UConn as
well how do we feel about this game
leading up to what do you think they're
feeling down here well you know the
nerves are out there they always are
whether you're playing a regular season
game and it's a tournament game or the
most important game in the season which
is the national championship game those
are a part of every game you play in but
this is the culmination I mean the NCAA
tournament is a long grinding event
college basketball it's a long grinding
season so for these kids to make it this
far the pressure only Rises and this is
where you separate the good from the
great in the national championship game
yeah they can take all the mess out of
the final four take a big sigh of relief
and now the game is here this is what
they came to do especially for San Diego
State first appearance of the final four
may never be back here again we had two
David's uh go go head to head and uh you
know San Diego State came out on top
over FAU so I'm excited tonight even
though everyone's going UConn I think
this is going to be much closer than
what people anticipated San Diego Stig
grinds it out makes it physical they got
to make it an ugly game and I think what
Tyler said before we got on air the San
Diego State team beat Alabama yeah
Alabama's got pros not and UConn's
playing great it's not to take away
anything they're doing but the fact that
they beat a team with that much talent
the way they defend they can hang around
in this game we are already underway
here with the first buckets of the game
by UConn but I think you guys are right
and you know they're here the chatter
San Diego State probably hears coming
into this one I mean it's been just a
grueling NCAA weeks of playing
basketball and like you said Tyler
they're just maybe a little bit
exhausted but the adrenaline's probably
still pumping especially from Saturday
night and how they got here they got to
be feeling all those things well I think
Lamont Butler is feeling a couple of
things after making that pull-up to send
his team here to the national title game
and then answering UConn's first bucket
with a big time three individual play we
talked a lot about that in the first
night here at the final four Matt
Bradley did it but now Lamont Butler
getting him started from distance San
Diego State's going to need scoring from
somebody and uh look here they just got
to turn over this is what they need to
do they need to make it ugly uh can't be
a beauty contest for San Diego for UConn
if if it happens if they let Hawkins get
off explosive score then it's gonna be a
long night but they got to lock him up
they got to contain sunogo and then also
they've got to find scoring whether it's
from Bradley Butler whoever ladies in
the home stretch of last game I think he
could cause some problems it just uh you
know it's got to come from somebody
before we get too far into the start of
this game let's talk about the locks a
little bit of the predictions for this
one Robbie you want to go first I wrote
mine down you wrote yours down
I didn't I couldn't remember what I said
last time there was a lot going on I got
UConn winning by eight and I've got
sunogo going for over 16 and a half
points and over eight and a half
rebounds Okay Tyler what you got that's
a solid lock uh I actually went with
rebounds because I'm a big man and I had
Andre Jackson uh for UConn getting over
yeah over six rebounds and uh kashed
Johnson for San Diego State going over
four rebounds somebody's gonna have to
get some rebounds and I know for San
Diego State they're bigs uh they're
going to have their hands full
especially with sunogo so I'm clicking
at uh looking at Johnson getting a lot
of rebounds for San Diego State okay
that's gonna be key my locks for this
game are definitely involving the three
ball I know that's been huge obviously
for Uconn and then defending it as well
for San Diego State so I put that Yukon
shooting under 33 from the three because
I think SDSU was going to lock them up
in that category and that's how they're
gonna either
make it a close game maybe win who knows
but I think that might be key for them
because Yukon 18-1 when they shoot over
36 percent from the three so that's
their bread and butter and where they
excel at and I'm sure that was all over
uh the game report for them and then
Yukon to win by six or more I do think
it's going to be closer than people
think as well I mean I'm hoping for
because who doesn't love a good game in
the national championship
um so I'm I'm going UConn by at least
six but it'll be close so you think that
San Diego State's defense gets back oh
yeah after giving up some three I've
been an all-term and long but exactly
they did get burned a little bit against
FAU and they didn't do what they were
normally doing for the you know games
before that so I'm thinking they're
going to clean that up tonight you just
got to take away sunoco's right hand too
I mean left shoulder he's been doing it
all tournament that's got to be on The
Scouting Report and also what I just
noticed they're not doubling out of the
post I was very curious to see how
dominant sunoco's been if they're gonna
double mins has been the defensive
player of the year in the Mountain West
the last two seasons and so you might
see them double to protect them it only
plays like 22 23 minutes a game but with
that being said you've got a center who
can hold a Zone he's a really good
Defender but Sunoco has been you would
think if he plays well tonight and UConn
wins he will be the mop of the final
four because of the way he's played
guys I've heard this before either in
the NBA in terms of the first quarter
score is important the halftime score is
important for college basketball the
first five minutes set the tone of the
game what do you guys think about it
just the first couple minutes you can
kind of sense what the tone is going to
be or you know it it doesn't really
matter it's always important you want to
get off to a good start I think San
Diego State certainly controlling the
tempo if it starts getting like this for
UConn's running up and down and hanging
on rims that's not good for the Aztecs
and there's a transition bucket right
there for UConn they want to control
Tempo take good shots take care of the
basketball yeah so San Diego State needs
to slow it down they can't get into a
track a track meet with Yukon and they
got to make it ugly but I've been on
both sides I mean I've come out to a
final four and we got off to a
horrendous start against Kansas and we
just couldn't come back uh we're
absolutely exhausted what did you guys
cut that game to I know they got on to
the really big lead early we actually
had a shot Danny Green top of the key to
actually take the lead so it got down to
a one possession game oh it got down to
one possession how much were you down by
it at its worst I would say 20. I
thought it was 20. yeah we got we got
deep in the hole it was a it wasn't
looking good but also San Diego State
has come from behind multiple games in
this tournament as you saw last game
against FAU uh they were down 14 at one
point came back and won the game so they
have the ability to come back a lot of
that has to do with they have a lot of
veterans on their player a lot of
experience I mean we've talked about it
at length now uh these some of these
guys 25 years old so uh
older than NBA teams out here for the
Aztecs oh my gosh I can't even believe
that sometimes they are they're Veterans
of this college team
do you think UConn is a little bit take
me through their mentality I mean San
Diego State may be hearing a little bit
of the chatter of could get blown out
could be you know whatever it may be is
UConn coming in feeling a little too
confident no I don't think that I think
in this first four minutes been a little
bit of a feeling out process and we we
heard a lot about how FAU in in the
initial Final Four game was going to
have to really sense and feel the
initial physicality of the game that San
Diego State brings because they you
can't simulate that you could say be
physical to your Walk-Ons and practice
but until you get the real deal out here
it's it's a whole nother animal so I
think it's always a feeling out process
regardless but especially with a defense
like this that's going to be every time
you cut through the lane they're holding
you they're chucking you they're making
you feel it so I think that always it's
a little bit of something where you go
to the bench right here and you're like
all right this is what it's going to be
yeah and also if I'm San Diego State I'm
pretty upset I mean nobody has really
taking them seriously I mean everyone
just says oh UConn's just going to kind
of roll through them I hope it's a close
game if I'm on San Diego State I'm like
nah no one's really even thinking about
this I'm coming out here trying to prove
a point we belong and uh if I'm UConn
though I don't think anyone needs to
play like a hero I think if they all
play good get production from everybody
they're gonna win they should win this
is how they got there guys this is you
you guys are reacting to that Butler
last second watching from home I thought
he's not gonna get the shot off the time
it did not look ready at all I was
screaming shooting because I've seen too
many too many games where somebody just
dribbles it and the time expires they
don't even get a shot off uh but yeah
interesting enough I think that's the
only time they took the lead in the
second half was on that shot so that was
pretty no time out called I mean
was Butler's did he have that plan in
mind or he's just dribbling it down the
court like let's see what happens he's
trying to make a play but all good
players understand end of the game
you've got the internal clock in your
mind you're you're making sure you look
at the clock and I thought that was the
most impressive part about that that he
knew I've got time even though I'm cut
off on the Baseline keep my dribble
alive between the legs one dribble and
I've got time to get a quality shot off
just because of how much Florida Atlanta
controlled that game is this one of the
best buzzer beaters we've seen or I
don't know I mean you're talking about
some Christian Laettner yeah
um you know the the NC State Houston
game from 83 there's a lot of I Gotta
Throw My Man Bryce throughout here
because I'm from Valparaiso Indiana so
bright
that was only a first round game and
we're like we're leaving out more I hate
to say it the Christian yeah Chris
Jenkins for sure Villanova to win
against my Tar Heels oh yeah and then my
favorite shot in the uh NCAA tournament
is when Luke may hit a shot in
they went on to win a National
Championship in 2017. that was a big
moment and my favorite shot in
tournament I think Jalen Suggs against
UCLA as well oh yeah in 2021 it was the
bubble end state tournament but half
court shot to go to the national
championship game and with some of these
shots you gotta like I love Bryce's shot
but it's a first round game right like
Christian laners is an elite eight shot
to go to the final four I believe
um if it's to win the national title
like it is with the Chris Higgins shot
that carries it carries more weight
right you know personal preference but I
think you have to take in what what the
situation is here we're looking at this
flashback right now yeah that was an
unbelievable
I mean it's definitely in the history
books for San Diego State for Butler a
moment he'll never ever forget
oh man this day in 2017.
wow
six national championships was that the
May year that's not the game
2017. but the year before Villanova hit
that shot to beat him with Chris Jenga
um yeah to win the title form it's just
got to be a different feeling hitting a
game winner though I mean obviously in
that magnitude but in any game I mean
hitting the game no it is it's a special
feeling I think is a whether you're a
good player great player All-Star and
bench player whatever you always want to
be put in that situation you want the
ball in your hands and when it comes to
you and you do make it there's no better
feeling yeah it's one of those moments
that when you're a kid and you're
playing on your you know backyard on the
playground it's something you make up in
your mind and you go through and then to
get to live that out for some of these
kids uh it's pretty incredible
especially on this stage no doubt and
you think about all the hard work that
goes into it how many times has Lamont
Butler shot pull-ups whether it's his
driveway or it's in the gym in San Diego
State or it's high school or wherever
you you are putting in that work so that
when the time comes and your number is
called and the opportunity presents
itself you're as prepared as you can
possibly be
I can't even imagine that's gotta be
something else
wow what do we think about the crowd
right now you guys were here Saturday
it's different watching from TV but what
do we think about this turnout I think
UConn students are still on spring break
that would never happen with like a
North Carolina I am blown away they
can't even fill up the student section I
know that's amazing good night
but otherwise I I don't know what do you
think do you think it's understanding of
State in in warm-ups it seems like it
lean towards San Diego State and yeah
but then when Yukon came out the last
time they sounded more equal now if
there's any neutral fans here we talked
about this before the game they'll be
Traders they will turn on Uconn and root
for the lower seed there's some people
jumping on the San Diego State bandwagon
there's a lot of red going on and
they're letting the play down low too
man they're just getting them on the now
UConn is a very good rebounding team so
so is San Diego State so this is going
to be interesting to who wins that
battle
UConn just has the rim protection with
sunogo and klingen there is never going
to be an easy basket and right there San
Diego San Diego State's getting multiple
opportunities getting on the offensive
glass but you've got sunogo and you have
to score over the top of him just take
away his right hand I mean just don't
let him get to that right hand hook boy
Tristan Newton kind of yeah I think he
maybe rolled his ankle there
where does Sunoco rank on big men just
in in college basketball yeah I mean I
think he's in the upper echelon of
players without Zach Edie
um you know the trace Jackson davises of
the world I think he's right there with
those guys he's been phenomenal in the
NCAA tournament he's averaging 20 a game
he's been the best big in the tournament
that's for sure if you're talking about
throughout the whole season uh he's same
category he's not he hasn't been as
dominant as Edie has uh but he's one
tier below that in my opinion
is he going to be the Difference Maker
today
I think that he's going to really test
them with his size and I think the
Klingon you could their front Court
could certainly decide this game
oh man I do think that behind Nate Mensa
they just don't have a ton of side
they've got physical bodies but if Mensa
gets in foul trouble we'll have to be a
rope or a lady that guards him
small walls
they called three three in the three in
the key
man he might spin to his left but it's
only so he can pivot to his right you
used to do that in the NBA was so good
at it was Luis Scola yeah ever Garden do
you ever guard Scola and he would pivot
and pivot and pivot you know until he
got back to his right hand he'd never
shoot with his left but he was so good
at getting back to his right he's one of
the most right-handed players ever ever
I played against him in China too man he
was he was very important he could like
go up and under and it would be a
left-hand shot and then he'd just pivot
right back to that right and just score
it over the top yeah Yukon up by two
right now let's take a look at some of
these San Diego State stats
first national championship appearance
in program history I mean this is just
Cinderella bookstore however you want to
see it first team to advance to title
game after winning both their Elite
eight and Final Four matchups by a
single point that one gets me to be able
to win both of those by just one point
and fifth program from California to
play in the national championship
I mean who saw this coming it's one of
those deals where to advance the NCAA
tournament you know you have to get a
little bit lucky you have to win some
close games maybe even find ways to win
some games that you don't necessarily
deserve to win but to beat Alabama you
have earned the right to be here the
Creighton game was a a classic battle
between two teams that really weren't
scoring it well but defending at a high
level and they've just they found their
way like Tyler's talked about you know
they've come back from second half
deficits that they've matched every
opponent they've needed to here in the
NCAA tournament and Brian Dutcher a long
time assistant for Steve Fisher what a
cool thing for him to follow coach
Fisher out to San Diego State then take
over and now take the program to place
it's never been
right hand hook
it's dead it's left shoulder every time
Ladi is never going anywhere else and
guys we are conversing with you guys in
the audience be sure to tweet
um and and ask your questions send them
in we've got one right here by Bertrand
should SDSU be considered a mid major
no the Mountain West has not been major
like the Mac to me is a mid major no no
offense to the Mac but conference is
like that I think the Mountain West
what's what's they've had four NCAA
tournament teams this year from their
league
to me that's not necessarily I consider
a mid major I'm sorry Mount West yes
absolutely I mean I haven't seen many
Mountain West teams in the final four of
recent no I agree
I mean yeah I just uh yeah I would
consider him a mid major I guess I look
at Mid Majors like Valparaiso and Ball
State and those to me are more mid-major
programs guys here's where we're at
right now with just uh Under 12 to go
here
in the first half San Diego State trail
in Yukon
12 to 10.
I thought we're gonna bring in some
guesses
because I'm excited guests coming on for
us
it's gonna be uh it's gonna be fun
asking these two over here some
questions but you can see right now
who's leading the way
tramel Butler
it's a no-go of course he's going to be
huge for what they're doing
8-0 run he just sets right there
foreign
as I try and gain this lead keep it
going
oh man Robbie this has been fun so far
oh it has this has been a really good
game certainly first four minutes both
these teams trying to kind of find their
way and feel each other out but the
Yukon huskies have so much Firepower and
certainly they're going to put pressure
on this San Diego State Defense all
night long
we're just getting started here it's
early
okay so with that we're joined by uh two
former Yukon Huskies teammates national
champs themselves played in the NBA
together Kemba Walker Jeremy Lamb here
thanks guys so much for coming in
appreciate it thanks for having us how
are we doing how are we feeling your
UConn team playing for a national title
how does it feel
we having a great time and hopefully we
win the game but if not we still
enjoying it and it's a great time how
stressful is it to be former players and
watch your school I mean it's way worse
than playing in this game it's stressful
you guys are really stressed and I know
how like
my parents and my friends and all the
fans
every time though I'm like come on like
I'm like
I just want to be out there yeah you
know what I mean I want to be out there
helping as much as I could but
unfortunately I'm in the stands at the
time so it was 13 years ago
um to the day
2012 2011. okay
you guys playing for National
Championship I mean what does that feel
like for them take us through their
mentality just there there can't be any
other feeling like it yes
it's pretty surreal like
yeah it really is like down to the last
two teams in the country
[Applause]
such a long season you know like every
team goes to like ups and downs you know
what I mean it's like
early in the season you could never
imagine being here and then when you
finally here
atmosphere was unbelievable and
it's just an unreal feeling it's an
unreal feeling yeah like I feel like
even realize
feeling when you're going through it
because
coming back I'm sitting here
it's like
incredible so when you're going through
it I don't there's no failure you just
going through it and you've done and
then later you like wow we did this it's
true you guys played in the old Big East
so certainly you saw tough crowds but
when when you're playing the final four
and you walk out here there's 80 000
fans I hated it really I hated it it's a
shooting or the shooting yes it's so far
like no I mean like it's so far it's
like it's not the same this is not the
same as like a regular college game
where everybody's on topic the floor in
the middle for you guys though yeah the
old ones they like when we played you
guys in Phoenix in the sweet 16 we
played in The End Zone yes and then they
brought the portable bleachers in and
there was like 170 yards nothing yeah
the corners were really hard but it was
in the middle yes sir we were in the
middle yeah yeah it's still just so
different it's like everybody's so so
spread out you know what I mean it's
just not normal so when you shoot it's
like
behind the basket you're gonna be in so
much space you know what I mean so it's
it's different it's different Kim but
how can we get you guys a student
section filled up yeah that's the fourth
goal man what's going on here because of
spring break I think no it was a little
overpriced
that's what I heard it was a little
overpriced you know for some of the
college students but you know back at
gamble they're showing super love so
it's all good we know that love is there
it don't matter we it don't matter yeah
but we got some fan we got some fan
questions for both of you I'll start
with you Kemba at Fair TG said what was
one thing you learned as a freshman that
you extended and taught everyone who
came after you one thing I learned
that's a great question um
oh man that was such a tough year man
um I mean to be honest it was really
just a hard work right
it wasn't hard work what it takes to to
really make it in the Big East the
biggest was so tough like my freshman
year I was I played in that six overtime
game against Connie Flynn which was
super tough like my jump shot wasn't
where I needed it to be
so I just kind of knew I had to work on
a whole nother level to become a great
player in this and it's tough degrees
man so it was the hard work like
whenever somebody underclassman came I
always throwing it the gym is over 24
hours yeah and that's it yeah Jeremy
what was
y'all's relationship like at Uconn and
then I mean you go on to play in the NBA
together which is wild as well but what
were you guys like you got
uh can y'all hear me yeah we can hear
you now the microphone's much better uh
he didn't really like me until let's
tell the truth that's what this is all
about tell us how it is he didn't really
like being child star hitting shots in
March Madness oh okay and then after
that
we was cool you know what I'm saying
then he left we didn't talk but then we
went to the Hornets
and it was like a dream come true you
played with your brother in college yeah
and then you go to the NBA with your
brother it was like amazing and uh
we've been cool ever since that's the
homie
um if I would ever get married he'll be
my best man
and um I love that now we chilling now
we're chilling wow that's not real it's
lying Kimber you're a point guard so you
wanted those assists right I understand
how that feels every time you kick it
out you want somebody to get that assist
for you they're gonna make some shots
you know if I'm gonna Pat you the ball
you got you got to make them right
absolutely while we guys have while we
have you guys here too we're gonna talk
about your all-time Yukon teams so first
at
djmdn13 Kemba who is your favorite husky
that came before you oh I love that
question and then we got to do your top
five so who is your favorite first my
favorite husky is Rudy Gay he actually
just walked in the building and to this
day I'm still like super excited to see
him like it was amazing so yeah Rudy Gay
is my favorite husky one of the reasons
why
UConn was my dream does he get slept on
when you're talking about the all-time
great players that played at Connecticut
no question no question I think so his
his talent was was unbelievable man like
Rudy was he he was a special guy at
UConn you know what I mean he was
special especially to me yeah
with that who wants to go first your
all-time your top five you want me to
read off like 20 players you can pick
them I I wrote them down you had it yeah
we all we all pick some so between Ray
Allen Rip Hamilton yourself crom Butler
Jeremy yourself ameka Okafor Ben Gordon
Rudy Gay Cliff Robinson Danielle
Marshall with theme to beat Shabazz
Napier caledona
George Chris Smith
[Applause]
Wait wait wait what was the you got to
pick five
all the time starting five all time
there's so many good players give me a
heart attack
I'm not gonna lie I'm going with the
first thing I'm going with is Shabazz
Napier
I'm going with him he's a he's a
two-time champ he has one by himself and
he has all with us which he was
absolutely super important and now and I
will run
um then I'm going Ray Allen Rip Hamilton
a Mecca Okafor and I'm going Rudy Gay
okay was that five what was that six I
think that was five
seven yeah
all right dear I'm gonna pick myself I
just I can't pick myself wait we got so
wait okay wait what was the five we got
three up on the board who are we missing
that you said hey pure Okafor Ray Allen
this man's humble and left himself off
the list yeah
for sure
that's a good I mean that is a good
thing that's a good team that's my five
right there all right that's a really
good team I like it Jeremy who you got
uh I can't pick five
why not
1037 no I mean
if you want I have the first team in the
second Team all UConn
I'm gonna have to go with um
wait
why didn't I have to answer uh who's my
favorite player oh who's your favorite
player start with that because they
should be on your top five I would think
right
so Rip Hamilton
is my favorite
because
he was like he made his niche in the
league with the like
like face mask oh yeah
and at that time everybody was like yo
what the hell is he doing
and then he just made it like perfect
I think he was like the best
we're not the best but we're one of the
best
but coming off screens was just like
automatic bucket okay and that was my
favorite all right we got four other
slots who who do you think how do you
want to fill them
okay ray
Ray Allen yeah right okay
[Music]
Quran Butler
uh uh
[Applause]
I seem to beat
wow it's different than yeah I like it
oh
AJ price Ben Gordon and Kay Waltz yeah I
mean we drove Dyson oh man those guys so
many it's hard to choose it's hard to
choose man all right I like it I got
Kimber in mind for sure I'll put you in
there Kimba I know I wanna you know why
because we we we're a blue blood
[Applause]
for sure
appreciate that because it's true
it's true
it's true we win this
can you take us can you guys take us
back to
playing San Diego State with Kauai
what what was that like what was playing
against Kauai in on the college level
like
didn't didn't know about Kawaii that
much yeah
no I mean
okay wait take his mic real quick
Kimba you gotta take Jeremy's mic for a
second share it
yeah we'll go back and forth yeah this
is better there we go um but yeah we
didn't we didn't know too much about
karate to be honest um we just knew that
they were a great team yeah we knew that
they were a great team they played
against
they played against Jimmer a lot
um but they talk so much trash that game
it was like that was the most intense
game we had in in the tournament yeah
really it was so much trash talking
going on like it was super super
competitive like super actually the SDSU
fans they were like yeah they were
yelling out that I was a Flopper because
I had a play back then where one of the
guys knocked me down they said I flopped
and all that but
know how that goes yeah
a flapper yeah they're pretty upset wow
I turned up after that you guys got the
last word though yeah oh for sure yeah
over everybody you know you guys played
in the NBA both of you have played in
the NBA for a long time if you put on
your your GM hat
who do you think on this Yukon team is
going to be the best pro
ah
I like Jordan Hawkins
um
as a pro I can see him doing big things
um he looked visibly ill yeah he could
tell he was really sick he's pretty
athletic
underrated actually like he's an
explosive scorer too and he can do it
from the three which I think is kind of
suited for the NBA right now but also I
kind of like clinging I think if klingen
gets his footwork no I agree and works
on his body like a walker Kessler type
build I could see him doing I agree that
kid is good man but I'm a huge fan of
Andre Jackson oh yeah I'm a huge fan I
think he's going to be a pro
um I know he's going to be a pro like
his his energy is unmatched man like and
that's what you need in the pros you
need a guy who can do it all like
everybody talks about his jump shot you
see him being like a Draymond yeah I
wouldn't say Draymond ah
I don't know who right now I wouldn't
say Draymond no but he's a guy who can
pretty much do it on I don't think as he
gets older I think he will develop the
the ability to shoot the basketball more
consistently for sure
Jeremy what do you think
[Applause]
Robbie ass who's the best pro who's
gonna be the best pro on this YouTuber
who would you draft yeah
uh for me I I don't know who would be
the best pro because
people get drafted in the second round
first round and are great so I feel like
it's a lot of people on the team that
could do damage so I don't know who
would be the best or the worst but
whatever it is we got I feel like we got
a lot if you were drafting would you
would there be a player you would draft
you like more than anybody else
um
that I would drive if you had a if you
had a pick somebody just one pick from
UConn Who Would you take
uh I kind of like to tell you guys you
talking about in like 2011. yeah
currently playing tonight
uh Dawkins
um Hawkins there
he uh I talked to him for a while
he's um I feel like he got a good work
ethic for sure um he always want to get
better so
I would definitely take him
um but like I said I'll take a lot of
people oh yeah I'm on the teams might be
a few Pros out there I'm with you Kimba
I like that it's gonna be good you can't
lead in the way right now 22 to 12 7 21
left to go in this first half
here's a couple of the the big
highlights so far what do we think how
is UConn taking the advantage
over SDSU so far energy the energy going
to small things you know loose balls 50
50 balls you got to get those man like
it's All the Small Things They really
really moving the basketball that's
super important man these guys play
together man like one thing you could
tell about them is is how much they love
to play with each other like on the
court like they they enjoy it and that's
one thing you could tell from afar
um and I appreciate that because that's
how we were and we wanted like we just
like we were so close I think that was
what got us over the hump to be honest
even though you didn't talk to Jeremy
for a while please aren't making shots I
was just I was just I was tough on them
that's what as you should have been
better it was a little skinny freshman
you know like I had to show them the way
you know I had to show up the way how
cool was it for you guys though to then
play professional basketball together
because college is and I wanna I wanna
hear from you because you guys both had
really really good Pro careers and and
still you know want to play but
is it different when you're playing in
college because you're living with these
guys and you're together all the time so
when you look back at those UConn teams
are those your favorite memories playing
last question no question like
no doubt about it but I I've had some
some pretty cool teams in the pros
um but College like
Second To None man like literally my
favorite time all time like these guys
were just amazing man like it was it was
such a great time being around these
guys and to this day like this is my
this is my this is my brother like you
know him bads like
these guys are like they got they hold a
special place in my heart for sure Kim
but you go back to UConn if you played
basketball thing these guys pick up or
anything
um no I haven't been back in a little
while to be honest um the last time I
went back was about I want to say five
years ago or so I went to um Midnight
Madness but to be honest I already plan
on on getting back you know as much as I
can now for sure yeah
Jeremy what was so special about
college basketball versus playing in the
NBA I mean do you agree with Kimba best
time of for sure it was it was amazing
for me because like
I went like to school so far from home
yeah
and it was just like they was like
family and yeah he was tough on me
but it made me like who I am and it was
just like amazing time like Roscoe Smith
um Tyler Nils giffy like we all like was
like brothers like we was real family
and uh
looking back on it that was like the
best time like basketball wise for me in
my career was it was amazing what was it
like playing in the old Big East where
you got Syracuse and Villanova and you
guys in Pittsburgh and Notre Dame and
Louisville and Cincinnati and Marquette
and and everybody else that was playing
that League what was that like when I
got to college
I was 160.
I was the smallest man in the Big East
that does not bode well for for the Big
East conference that year it was not fun
how tall how tall were you I was like
six four yeah six four one sixty 160. oh
it was so bad
yeah it was pretty bad he was oh come on
now
they go out Pro right there man Jordan
Hawkins man let's go
come on now
but yeah Jaylen was skinny
at the Big East was was at first it was
tough but the best thing about it was
how he grew you know what I mean like
that was the best thing about it and
what I think about now was like we
didn't do so well in the Big East I
think we finished ninth so
but as I think about it like all the
losses we we had in the Big East and
like the struggles we had like it
literally
they literally wear lessons what I mean
like at the time you know realize you're
like damn we just keep losing we keep
losing but those are like huge lessons
for us like we learned so much from
those losses that when we got into into
into the Big East tournament
it was over yeah we were locked in like
we became closer and closer and closer
like man and these guys like Jay Lam he
became a whole different player like at
that point we tell them we're telling
him and Shabazz and those guys nails and
Tyler like bro they're not fraction
anymore like it's over like the Freshman
stigma is is done like grow up you need
y'all I need y'all like did it make you
sad the league is no longer and the Big
East is it seems like there's a real
Resurgence coming Rick Pitino is now
going to be the head coach at St John
and and Creighton was knocking on the
door of the final four here but does it
make you sad that it's no longer the 16
team animal that it was and you guys are
playing a little bit sad man for sure
because
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's like football out there man it was
make you tough man especially when you
playing against Pittsburgh
it was the worst like Sam young yeah who
would you go up again you might have
missed Sam young I don't even remember
his name but he slapped me in the head
no foul called nothing they just went
down to oh my God who would who would
Jeremy have been talking about like
DeJuan Blair was the dude that could
shoot
Ashton Gibbs yeah
my boy my boy Brad wanted to make his
shots
he's had a really good career oh Brad is
overseas and then grinding to the NBA to
be honest Brad is like
he's one of the best human beings I've
ever been around to be real like Brad
want to make it his mom that's my God
man he's such a such a solid dude in New
York City he is Philly Philly He's a
Philly guy he's a Philly guy yeah I play
with him in Boston man like that's one
of my favorite teammates ever for real
yeah he was really cool we and we talked
about that shot a lot he he hates it
when I bring it up okay my bad hey you
know who hates him more Gary poor
Garrett is going to watch that every
March you did that to him yeah that was
special times man guys man this was so
fun having you both on talking a little
2011 Yukon watch oh lost his shoe there
[Applause]
your Yukon Huskies leading the way right
now just straight out of the shoe oh wow
we really appreciate that you guys
coming on chatting with us talking about
memories all the good things good to see
you both
good luck to the Huskies here appreciate
it thank you guys so much
all right this is where we're at right
now 26-15 still 5 32 left in this first
Robbie Tyler
what does San Diego State need to do
to close out this first half try to even
up the score a bit well making a shot
would be helpful that'd be a good place
step one they've got 17 points here so
that's not a good deal but I think
really my biggest takeaway of so far is
we've talked so much about San Diego
State's defense but UConn's defense has
been a lead as well and even though San
Diego State some teams it can go cold
and has not been an offensive Juggernaut
by any means UConn's defensive but in
the story of tonight's game so far
putting up just 17 points like you said
here I mean there's still plenty of time
left in the first but
17 to 30 you just you don't want to dig
too far of a hole Tyler like you were
saying before no you don't want to get
in the hall against uh UConn this is an
FAU they have too much fire power to
really come back but
you know somebody's gonna have to step
up make some plays uh Matt Bradley might
have to hit some shots
um or it might have to come from ladies
like it did against FAU I don't know
somebody's gonna have to step up but
also this game isn't going the way uh
that San Diego State wanted to just
because UConn if Jordan Hawkins is going
to explode and score it's going to be a
long night uh for San Diego State
I know they're trying to
get that offense going make something
happen here before closing out this
first half
oh that doesn't help Tristan Newton is
one of those guys he just made a big
three in transition he's one of those
dudes that flies under the radar for
this team but he's got two triple
doubles on the year
he's shooting it well in the NCAA
tournament from the three-point line and
they're in transition that's the benefit
of having Andre Jackson who's a big
point guard that could find his shooters
man shooting just San Diego State two
and just 24 27 percent now the Huskies
61. what's new country from three
all right
but it's still not helping them
minus 13 is not helping right now uh if
they can continue to defend but make a
couple shots that'd be good
boy casual with that come on let's go
lay it up
how hard is that to miss a layup I mean
at any well I just don't understand why
I didn't secure the when you miss a
layup it automatically becomes an open
shot on the other end you see it all the
time but the way that that he went
tremel went so casual didn't use two
hands and just kind of laid it up there
and now that's a huge five-point swing
yeah to miss a layup and especially not
run back on defense and to give Yukon an
open look from three-pointer this is not
going San Diego State's way this is not
they don't want to turn into a track
meet like we had talked about but also
to just give that open look that open
three
is gonna be it's gonna be a long night
for San Diego State
San Diego State trailing Yukon by 16. we
still got just over three here in the
first
like you said they just got to make some
buckets try and get some points on the
board to try and make this a little bit
closer of a game we got another guest
coming for us Renee Montgomery
where I'm gonna listen I already told
y'all last game I was gonna be
ridiculous when somebody come look at
this
look at this it's gonna get up it's good
you think they're gonna run away I was
gonna say you want a good game I mean I
want a good game for everybody else like
just for for y'all I want a good game
you asking me for me yeah I want them to
run it up what you mean they've won by
15 points every game this tournament
that's already the most of any team why
not make history tonight I don't know
why not why not we ain't here I mean you
saw the Yukon folks that just left some
of my teammates are coming through so
we're here
[Applause]
our research team dug deep we looked
into the Jonathan name oh
the story he is named after the original
governor of the state of Connecticut
from like
Jonathan Yeah well yeah because we were
talking about who names their dog
Jonathan Jonathan and you know our
research team is really in-depth and
really really good so that's a little
like a logical reason I was wanting
something with a little more yeah it's
dated or Jonathan Trumbull the first
governor of the state of Connecticut
though actually yesterday so you know
he's it's a real thing at UConn but I
don't know about the name man she's
still laughing
I've heard about the viral tweet
Jonathan Bill Murray took a picture
together right what nice lucky John I
think that's what I think that's what
they said I mean him like turnt up I
love sports man it's like what is he
doing so many people together I know and
I also heard about the last show you
were on you got a little something that
a little chip that I mean gold gold I
got a free Frosty every time I pull up
because I was you know when they say for
a year I'm like what does that really
mean does that mean once a week like you
could go every day baby every day have
you been this is you right here I've
been working I was gonna say I know it
works at over there yeah man that came
hang with y'all and the red sexy seats
you know what I'm saying we out here you
could literally go three times a day get
yourself a frosty Wendy's hooking you up
faster Wendy's man if y'all want to date
High Lab Wendy's hooking you up please I
like what you did with the place I like
it here
oh man we like it here too this one's
been fun okay this is the tweet I was
talking about though who's more famous
oh yeah filler Jonathan I don't know
where Jonathan yeah look like a Jonathan
yeah is that husky look like a Jonathan
to you named after the governor or
everyone knew that that's the most
obvious thing it could be Bill Murray
yeah I know I don't know who would who
would you want to take a picture with
more
I mean I already got Jonathan so I guess
Bill okay I mean Jonathan is the homie
at this point yeah he is
oh my gosh yeah he is okay let's talk a
little bit while this is continuing on
back here right the Women's Championship
game okay yes tell me your thoughts
about it I mean I watched it start to
finish a lot of different opinions what
do you think yeah no there's a lot of
opinions the first opinion everybody
needs to have is look out because the
ratings came out 10 million people 10
million humans were watching that game I
don't know 10 million humans are even
watching my Yukon Squad right now but
just the women's game I mean I saw my
whole timeline was talking about it I
saw celebrities rappers I heard the
flashes about to do a track with little
Wayne a championship track by you Barbie
told Mattel to come the name image and
likeness deals are flowing the players
are balling man I mean that's what I
take from it I mean I wish that like I'm
so happy that we've gotten to the point
where it's mainstream you know it's not
about like hey did you happen to see the
women's game like if you didn't see it
what you doing yeah no you know worry
about that and I think that you come
from a unique place because you are a
co-owner of a WNBA team there's 144
spots in the WNBA and it feels like
women the college game for women's
college basketball is it's healthy as
it's ever been with with the talent and
the parody you know it's not like
there's just one team that we got
superstars in multiple leagues
there's only 36 draft picks how how do
we make it to where these stars because
not all of them are going to be able to
go to the W you know it's just it's a
good point the WNBA is the hardest
League to be in even statistically
turnover is just not yeah so there's 144
players that can make it so when
everybody talks about two percent of
these athletes that y'all see playing
that you love obviously GoPro and the
WNBA is less than one percent because
there's just not a lot of spots to your
point we got to expand like it's just
there's no other solution there needs to
be a landing spot we started a certain
way because you want to build and grow
the league but it's healthy now baby I
mean I think it's time that we want to
see because people want to follow a
college star to the pros and we need to
connect if they're going overseas it's
just they're playing 10 hours ahead and
it's just impossible I did it for 10
years yeah it's like you're almost
forgotten over there because it's like
you're playing you could even be winning
championships and you come back and
you're excited about it and no one
really cares because nobody's really I
mean it's wild four o'clock in the
morning when you want to
you just want the players to be able to
just live their best lives play at the
highest level train at the highest level
we don't have off Seasons you know like
you go from WNBA season two weeks
overseas then straight back into WNBA so
yeah that's the maturation of the game
right there and Renee I want to ask you
this too here's some of the highlights
from that national championship game but
just Angel Reese Caitlyn Clark how much
media attention they brought to the
entire thing because in my mind
they really just started I don't know if
it was a trend or what but they got so
many people hype about what was going on
in women's college basketball that I
think that's why there was so much
viewership definitely I mean first of
all they have to be Stars no one cares
if you're not good so the reason that
people were talking about Caitlin Clark
is because what she's doing on the court
is wild and Coach Ariana said yes we've
seen Diner and Taurasi do it before
she's the oh come on
but what she's doing on this level I
mean the timing of her shots she got the
Ultimate Green Light that's why you're
starting people are comparing her to
people like Steph Curry you don't get
that Ultra green light like I mean I'm
just saying you have to earn an ultra
green light and she has it and she's
performing and then you know Angel Reese
she just set a new record for double
doubles just doing her thing leads in
has 17 name image and likeness deals and
I say that because that's big in the
women's game you know like we weren't
necessarily getting deals before so I
mean it's just turning up and for me
being a WNBA owner I love to see it
because if the people are following the
college game then they come to the WNBA
more viewership more better deals it's
just all about growth right now what's
it like to own a team do you ever like
warm up I know can you ever tell us
I'm on the team honey okay probably in
training camp you can ask I'll be at
training camp sitting there like this
like no no they got to move the ball
they gotta move the ball come on what
you doing like you're really Hands-On
owner I'm sitting coricidal at the games
I'm Turnt Up I'm like remember two years
ago that was my teammates people still
playing on my team were my teammates
when I was on the team so it's a
different type of feel it's and that's
kind of awkward too and when it comes to
your business when the decisions need to
be made yes that's awkward but I always
say like the sports business I have
teammates that we didn't play against we
played against each other but you still
friends like you know so that's kind of
how I treat ownership like even if
you're not on our team anymore we still
family so I got a question about uh the
championship game yesterday how'd you
think it was officiated do you think
Caitlyn Clark deserved that technical
because I don't I don't I don't think I
don't want I want the refs to just be
gone and just chill out like call
whatever's necessary I would rather a
physical game with the Stars in it than
uh let's say a tightly officiated game
and we're looking at Angel Reese on the
bench the whole second quarter we're
looking at Caitlin Clark on the bench
this is not why the people showed up we
showed up to see the stars and it
happened the semifinals game two with
Aaliyah Boston she got in foul trouble
so I would much rather even as a player
let us battle it out and figure it out
rather than call Ticky tack fouls and
our stars are on the bench Jeremy Lamb
was just talking about he used to get
hit in the face blood falling down and
they just keep talking about the old big
ears the old Big East he said was brutal
for him his freshman year the game is
much softer now okay great yeah because
when you played I mean I've seen you be
bloodied up before too oh yeah everyone
remembers that I mean it's as we get
older people always you know the older
players always say ah the game's soft
now and it is a little bit small balls
made it a little bit softer and they
call the game a little bit differently
but back when we played especially you
in the Big Ten uh it was very physical
it's not as soft as it is now I'd just
say that but you know I miss the
physicality of the game so question
because at UConn when I was playing
there our ogs used to come back and like
pretty much whoop us like Diana would
come back and give and get us in trouble
in practice and then we'd be in trouble
for a week and other players like that
do you ever do y'all ever go back I can
give him some buckets
my knee won't won't take that now but
back in the day I used to go back every
summer as did a lot of other Pros Marvin
Williams used to come back Sean May used
to come back uh Brendan Haywood used to
come back all these guys so that's a
great thing kind of like UConn is you
have all these you know good Pros that
have gone on they come back and they
play pickup in the summer exactly it
makes it great every time yeah they did
yeah they gave us impressive I will say
though as a former ex-player and I think
most players are like this and I want to
hear if you think that's about genome I
go back to practice or shoot around I'm
like don't listen to music
they're not he's not yelling at them all
the time he's not sending guy to the top
of the Arena what is happening I'm like
this dude is not even the same person
that I've played for has Gino gotten
soft too 100
it's just different I mean I'd even
think about our preseason workouts and
how Wild it is but I think things had to
change like you know what I mean it's
like I feel like though with Yukon the
the success was in the routine of it and
they still do the same routine and stuff
but you got name image and likeness you
got the portal combat games also two
players will literally let's leave
they will leave and so I think coaches
have to kind of adjust to that because
you can't be like imma just do what I do
and then players leave left and right so
then you've got three players on your
team literally literally are you
recruiting a whole new Squad every year
so it's just a different vibe but I mean
for UConn it's interesting because this
is a humbling moment for us in a sense
of everyone there's parody around the
league and men and women I mean we had
here we had a team in San Diego state
that's never made it it's a concert down
there I know what it's turned up I'm
here for it I mean it's just it's parody
now you can just see it women's game
men's game everybody as much as we've
been chatting we've been watching the
game but let's let's look at the first
half highlights because right now Yukon
36-24 lead what are you seeing in your
in this Huskies team that's getting them
out to such a good start this first half
yeah I saw UConn in the beginning
getting I mean
wow get into the loose balls first
dominating the paint all of that I've
seen also though San Diego State came
out hot they made their first three
shots they made a three they made a two
they got a rebound okay I just you know
I've been seeing a lot of things but I
know a lot of people want a close game
this is exactly what UConn does little
by little they extend the lead every
single game to where it's just Out Of
Reach and before you know it you're up
by 12. this is our halftime squaring up
presented bye Wendy's we're going to
look at two of the players from uh both
these teams here compare them a little
bit
sunogo Lamont Butler obviously Butler
with the game-winning shot in the game
that got them here
um Robbie what do you think so far of
how sunogo has played this first half I
mean I love the way he's played here in
the first half certainly getting on the
glass he's scored it I think that at
times like all teams do they don't throw
the ball inside enough you know give the
big fellow the ball if he can have
one-on-one coverage you got to make San
Diego State pay for that it's gonna be
him versus Nathan Metz all night long
squaring up presented by Wendy's Wendy's
hooking us up all night long hook and
Renee up all year long with her free
frosties all right Tyler what do you
think Butler San Diego State what are
they talking about in that locker room
right now I think they've got to get
scoring from somebody they got to get
Matt Bradley involved he came out hot
last game they got to get in the D's
involved they've got to somehow put
sunogo into those ball screens and make
him defend the perimeter uh they can't
just let him beat you up inside but I do
think that you can't continue to let
sanogo get it down low they're going to
have to double they're gonna have to
switch it up they're gonna have to do
something different to get their way to
get themselves back into this game and
UConn has dominated points in the paint
and that speaks to a lot of to what
sunogo does 16 to six points in the
paint this is our halftime squaring up
presented by Wendy's
they gotta figure out a way to make
shots defend a little bit better here
against the Steve Crossing but like you
said they're scoring little by little
and then before you know it you're down
by 15. definitely in the two-man combo
that was all season long was Jordan
Hawkins and Adam sunogo they were
averaging 32 points together in the
season but Jonathan Jordan Hawkins in
the tournament we talk about the 90 50
40 club it's an elusive Club KD Kyrie
Dirk Elena Delle Donne very few people
can 90 from the free throw line 50 from
the 3 50 from the field goal 40 from the
three Jordan Hawkins is doing that
during the tournament small sample size
uh-oh we back again it's a small sample
size
but 90 50 40. okay do you always have
this much energy Renee I've worked with
you before on different themes I know
this is a different uh experience than
what we've worked on before but are you
always as energetic I mean I'm Turnt Up
but you got a little extra Zach on today
because the Yukon effectiveness
come on like you got to remember why are
fans so crazy about their universities
because you kind of are part of it well
as an athlete I feel like we were even
more a part of it because it's a family
like Jeremy Lamb and Kimba that just
walked out of there when we saw each
other it's like what up family because
that's just what it is I'm sure it's the
same for y'all too I didn't have to play
at the same time
at UConn to know that we're still like
family there yeah take us back to when
you guys want it what that feel they
were Kimba and Jeremy both talking about
how there's just nothing like it playing
in the you know in the NBA their careers
that they've had but there's nothing
like
college basketball and of course winning
that always helps too would you agree I
mean because in the pros you got to
think about it we're playing in series
so there's not really this kind of
pressure on one game it's like we
dropped the first game all right y'all
we got to win the next two you drop the
second game all right we can't lose
anymore but with March Madness our team
was undefeated coming into the
tournament so my whole thought was who
wants to go all the way to the
tournament undefeated just to lose one
game and be done I was stressed out I'm
not gonna lie coming into the tournament
it was my senior year I went to UConn we
had one yet so that's just a weird thing
to go through Uconn and not win a
championship so I just remember the
night before the game I'm running
through everything that I can do to help
my team who do I need to get the ball
first what kind of touches can I get
them how are they guarding our post
players I'm watching extra film I'm like
an over prepare when I get nervous and I
just remember being like there's nothing
they can throw at me that I can't be
prepared for right now what's your best
Geno story say what what's your best
chinorium story oh man it probably was
when they kicked us out man like coaches
kicked us out not a practice of the
whole locker room why get your stuff you
can't wear the yukon's name on your
chest what year was this oh my junior
year I think yeah why'd he do it because
you know like there's a certain standard
you lost games or you just practice it
was a practice I'll tell you what we
talking about practice I'm gonna tell
you
preseason
even in the season just so you guys can
get an idea he was just like this is
just not the way UConn handles
themselves in all aspects I think you
know we might have skipped the class in
summer school if I'm being honest so it
just got a little fugazi and coach was
like yeah no we're not doing those class
Checkers gotcha I got it it's good you
know what I mean a little bit of a
different time like we were talking
about when you guys all played versus
The Players now you mentioned Tyler
being all bloodied up before the refs
not calling anything I think we got a
little something about it right here
look at this thanks a lot Gerald that
was fun did they call a foul yeah they
called the foul on that one I would hope
so was your nose broken for real yeah it
was broken wow actually that didn't hurt
that bad but uh I thought there was a
chance it wouldn't be broken but as much
blood that was coming out of my nose I
knew something was wrong but yeah that
was a
you was trying to get somewhere just now
where was you going you were like
talking into someone uh Gerald Henderson
elbowed me there and I had no clue who
hit me and so I was gonna go after
somebody
I think it was Demarcus Nelson who I was
going to go after and it would have been
the wrong player uh it would have looked
bad looking back on it but I was I was
fired up uh but really I didn't know
what was happening until I saw the
replay I have worked with Gerald
Henderson before he has brought this
situation up has apologized before I've
worked for Gerald too we're cool now but
for years I was going to get them I
wasn't over for a long time NBA wherever
I was going to get them back that's
called on site the worst part though
about getting in the nose is that your
eyes water like your eyes just just it's
like you're crying but you're not and
you can't see I was playing a game in
Russia and me and Jacob Paul were on the
same thing same team and we collided and
I broke my nose and I can cut you for
sure and the team doctors they made me
go to a hospital and they were like this
is used by the Russian astronauts it's a
very good hospital and I'm concussed so
I'm like all right cool it'll be good
and then in my mind I'm thinking the
Russian space program has not been
relevant since like the 80s
no one spoke English they came in they
were trying to set my nose I was like no
no I'm flying back to America I'm
booking my flight but I spent the night
in a Russian Hospital
in English concussed and my nose still
bleeding into into the next day overseas
is different ball games yes it is
physicality is it physical would you
when you went overseas you're kidding me
this like you were the American cloak so
if you're an American overseas they're
like oh you can handle it it's nothing
playing the refs just totally job you
all the time
so I know all about what you're talking
about I feel like we all probably played
in Russia but yeah it's it's a different
world and when you play overseas they
want you to get 20 rebounds 20 assists
20 like everything like you they want
you to do a lot I'm not kidding wow I
played in China it was like the NBA and
they want you to score a million points
if you're not scoring you're going yeah
yeah it is uh I think my more might have
played in uh China because they were
talking about her when I was over there
but yeah it's China has a huge
basketball following but it is physical
in fact Dwight Howard might be playing
Taiwan right now on right now you were
in Moscow no I was in uh chevicada oh
and orenberg but that's I played I put
their three years actually but that
those are smaller cities yes at least
mascot you got some American brands I
never play in the big city oh man I
never small ones I always thought for
the Americans playing the small cities
I'm just a small town but it's even
worse if you're a small town girl in
small town
Russia yeah to bring it back a little
bit to this game that's going on right
here it is halftime but we want to know
what you guys think can SDSU make a
compat come back make sure you let us
know in the chat I mean they're not
they're not down by that much it's not
like it's you know 20-point game right
now this March Madness anything can
happen it is March Madness it is the
national championship game it is a
Monday in Houston anything can happen I
think they were down 14 against FAU they
were uh now fau's not Yukon but it is
possible and also I think uh San Diego
State has come from behind and a lot of
their victories in the tournament they
can grind it out what they need to do is
they need to contain Jordan Hawkins slow
him down uh figure out how to contain
snow go inside too and just keep
battling and win the rebound War I will
say I do worry about them coming back
from a deficit against this UConn team
because the defense is so Stout and just
because San Diego State has those
scoring droughts and you're only one or
two of those away from this being 18 or
20 with a as explosive as they are now
that they can't come back but I think
UConn's going to be the next champ I
really do yeah I think that when it
comes to San Diego State the first thing
they're probably telling each other in
the locker room is look we were down 14
like Tyler said in the second half they
don't care that it's not the same team
anymore when you're in the moment
they're not going to worry about that so
if you're UConn you almost have to wipe
your mind clean and not pay attention to
it because honestly everybody on every
set's been talking about how dominant
Yukon is ignore all the media ignore
even the noise right now because we've
seen crazier things happen in March
honestly absolutely you can see this
poll right here people are voting can
SDSU come back in this second half
some are saying yes others say you know
UConn's going to win it all San Diego
State have they've won the last two
games by a point so this is kind of
their bread and butter is to Rally come
back from behind the deficit game
whatever you want to call it this is
something I think they're going to make
a game of it but like you said UConn's
going to come in there knowing this is
March Madness let's wipe the table start
from zero I mean San Diego State has won
in a variety of ways people said well if
they get into the scoring of 70 San
Diego State can't win they gave a 40 in
the first half to FAU 30 in the second
half still one by one and then we've
seen them shut down teams some of the
most prolific offensive teams so they've
been resilient you have to give San
Diego State Credit they have found a way
to win no matter the matchup whether it
was a small team big team scoring team
defensive team and they've had almost
one of the toughest roads to actually
get to the championship game they're
Fighters they're fighting I mean what
Tyler said before the show if you beat
Alabama you can beat anybody in this in
this tournament because Alabama has
dudes and Pro goes and they beat them so
they certainly can I I just think
UConn's playing too well I really do
they look like by Far and Away the best
team in this tournament like Kevin and
Jeremy were saying they're playing so
together he said he hasn't seen
something like he said It reminds him of
the 2011 team that won when he was there
definitely I mean they went 14-0 to
start the season and then they go in the
end conference play drop a bunch in a
row I think they dropped five out of
eight at a certain point and then there
was a lot of questions asked because
they weren't in the preseason top 25. so
then they get through that stint which I
think really helped them they had to
figure some things out adamasinogo was
like yo guys this is on me we got to
play better I'm gonna be a better leader
and then ever since that moment I call
it a come to Jesus meeting y'all know
the meetings that you have ain't no
coaches in there it's all the players
and you just got to be real with each
other they have one of those meetings
and then ever since then it's been a
certain type of trajectory where
everybody's heard about the team only
not saying they weren't before but
everyone knew they had to do a little
something different and step it up and
now like you said it seems like they're
just so jailed and the chemistry is
right do you think do you think this is
a dominant team or do you think they're
just on a really good streak because
they are four seed and a lot of people
now that they're just kind of blowing
out the field they're kind of projecting
them as like a dominant Powerhouse team
I think they've had a good run but
there's a reason there are four seed and
they could they've shown some
vulnerabilities so I'm just curious do
you think this is a dominant team or
just on a really good stretch right now
I think this is a dominant team I mean
look at who they beat before they played
in conference in conference is what
actually hurt UConn to make them a four
seed coach Dan Hurley talked about we're
a tough team to play the first time
because we're big we're also a scoring
team we play defense but once you're in
conference and start playing them a
couple of times teams start to figure
them out that's not how the tournament
works though uh oh here we go again here
we go again that's not how it works but
that's not how the tournament works so
they're playing teams for the first time
I think they beat Alabama earlier in the
season yeah in Portland yeah Portland so
Tyler you said that if you beat Alabama
you're good enough to win a championship
they did that in the beginning of the
Season before they probably were even
jailed so Jordan Hawkins is the only guy
that's looking at a top 10 lottery pick
that same team might be back next year
missing Jordan Hawkins which is missing
16 points per game their three-point
leader all of that but yeah I think if
this team comes back even missing Jordan
Hawkins I don't know I feel like they'll
be in the polls do you think Sunoco and
Klingon would come back on the same team
do you think both of those guys because
Klink is going to have to he's going to
have to get more minutes in my opinion
he's been too dominant with the amount
of minutes he's gotten do you think
those two can play on the court at the
same time listen boosters okay listen a
call to action here listen Linda
um I do though it's hard to leave a team
that wins so you know like if you win
you're going to receive a lot of success
so the deals are going to start flowing
right now after this game's over do you
want to leave and go somewhere else I
don't know I mean I think it really
comes down to what coach Hurley tells to
him because I I've heard even coaches we
were talking to well I'm not going to
say what coach but I was talking to a
coach before and he was saying he told a
player look you're telling me you need
20 minutes to stay you should go and so
maybe a coach might tell somebody look
if that's what you're going to want in
the season so I think that's more of a
Dan Hurley how does he see it but I do
feel like there's a way to make it work
but you're right he has to get more
minutes I mean he's too dominant if
Yukon pulls this out where do you put
them with the other national
championship teams are they considered
one of the all-time great teams in UConn
history then I mean they have to because
look at their tournament performance
they have one of the most dominant
performances in NCAA history so when the
numbers start to back things like that
you have to give them credit I mean
coming into this season UNC was the
preseason number one team did not make
the tournament then you got Yukon not in
the preseason polls at all wins a
championship but don't oh sorry Tyler oh
I knew you had to bring it up it's all
good I'm numb to it now to come in and
do what they did in the tournament when
a lot of people weren't talking about
UConn winning it was more of a different
I mean all the ones are gone so
obviously those were the lead Runners
but to do what you did at a four seed
and to do the damage each game you got
to talk you're not just winning yeah
winning you're confident you are
dominating Renee man you have been such
a treat
about to go scream enough but I gotta
keep my voice oh man this second half
you're gonna have so much fun watching
we appreciate you coming on here
free Wendy's frosties for my goodness
okay let's take a look at this first
half a little bit more be our final four
live presented by Wendy's we're getting
ready for the second half UConn San
Diego State
one more half to a national championship
crowned okay 36-24
I mean the shooting percentage obviously
that's the biggest thing the biggest key
that we're seeing here from the three as
well hopefully San Diego can make a
couple baskets this next half that'll
even up things a little bit that's where
obviously the biggest difference is it's
funny we were having the same
conversation at halftime of the FAU game
we were like man San Diego State's got
to get some easy buckets around the rim
you have their defense create some
offense in transition get to the foul
line but but when you're shooting 28
from the field and 27 from three and
going up against the Yukon defense it's
been terrific all tournament long and an
offensive as as explosive as anybody
they're gonna have to get it done with
their defense and that's gonna have to
help their offense as well here yeah
sometimes your defense is your best
offense and somebody's gonna have to
step up the one thing that I I will say
is different tonight is Matt Bradley
came out of the gates ready to go he
gets FAU and then uh you know he's the
coach sub them out which I I was uh I
couldn't believe but somebody's gonna
have to step up and also they haven't
made it easy on themselves they missed
some point blank layups uh I don't know
if it's nerves or whatever or just the
dominant presence of Uconn is just
intimidating but they're gonna have to
make some layups they're gonna have to
find a way to get some easy buckets get
their confidence going maybe go to the
foul line get some fouls and then
they're going to start seeing some easy
buckets
and I think for UConn too the turnovers
they had three or four women at the end
of the first half right there that's a
Surefire way to jump start the San Diego
State offense so you've got to take care
of the basketball and it's always a big
part of things but especially against
the physicality that San Diego State's
going to bring out here if you're having
a bad shooting game
what is the ticket is it okay let's get
to the free throw line let's try and
make a couple shots here if you're oh
for four or over five and you're like
okay nothing's going in is that what the
mindset of a player is let's just get to
the free throw line yeah layups and free
throws yeah where you get your jump
start I think it's at some point as a
player you're always expecting your next
shot to go in it's not like you're
shooting to miss but it does help when
you get some layups you get some
momentum going uh some rebounds making
some plays uh to get some momentum
whether it's a steal a rebound or even
just making a big charge it can shift
the momentum it's funny how that can
change your shot too and get you guys
you know get San Diego State some easy
buckets going in I think it's amazing
how at the start of games when you see a
shooter get a layup those shots all of a
sudden start going in because you gain
confidence from making a one foot shot
you feel good about yourself and it's
just it's amazing it shouldn't help that
much but you see it all the time it's
the real deal you make a layup you make
a free throw you get to the foul line
and your confidence the shooter just
grows exponentially just seeing the ball
go in the hoop is a big deal I played
high school basketball for fun in
college nothing nothing past that but I
I would have coaches just say you know
effort defense is something that you can
bring every single night it doesn't
matter if your shots are falling or not
things travel what it yes what tell me
some advice coaches have maybe given you
guys if you know you weren't shooting
like how you would want to or how how
it's going so far for you I mean I think
for me it was always can I affect the
game in other ways and that's why it was
so hard for me as a pro especially at
the NBA level where it's like I'm out
here to make threes and if I don't make
threes then I I I'm really what am I out
here for right but at the college level
it was a different animal you're out
there rebounding you're out there
defending you know you can make plays
for other people whereas an NBA player I
basically stood in the corner you know I
mean I stood in the corner and when the
ball came to me I shot so at this level
you're just trying to to affect the game
in as many ways that you can well
sometimes you put too much emphasis on
scoring yeah and I know San Diego State
we're talking about that but they need
to score uh especially tonight but also
to impact the game in a positive way
whether that's defensively bringing a
good attitude getting out and passing
Lanes or just playing hard there's
always something you can do to have a
positive impact on the game so
somebody's gonna have to do that but
also tonight let's just be honest they
got a score yeah I gotta figure somebody
out it's got to get they got somebody 24
points in the first half you're
absolutely right oh wow oh my gosh the
second half officially underway
thinking about this too guys this is the
last college basketball game for some of
these guys yeah
what I mean you obviously
hope to have a good game even if you
don't whatever it may be but just that
thought the emotions of it talking to
you too Renee Kemba Jeremy it's like
college basketball the best time of your
life no it is and this could be the last
one and I think that's something you
have to kind of put to the back of your
mind you have to focus on The Scouting
Report you have to focus on being a good
teammate doing what you do out there and
it can't be something that enters hey
this this is the end of the road win or
lose like there is not going to be a
game tomorrow it's a weird feeling but
it's something that you have to deal
with when you make it to this level yeah
and for me uh when I was in college
especially my senior year there was so
much pressure on my team to actually
winch National Championship because
we're so talented that when the last
when we won the National Championship
was just a big relief yeah and you know
UConn coming into this final four was so
dominant and everyone picked them to win
I gotta imagine that there's going to be
some type of belief once this game is
over
18 minutes 30 seconds till somebody is
named a national championship 2023
NCAA national champ you can see the
energy the effort that San Diego State
is coming out with in the second half
that's a constant with their program I
mean they are always going to play hard
they are always going to defend and the
question mark always for them is when
they play Elite teams can they get
enough scoring and that that question in
the first half was a big no
I agree I think we're gonna have to have
scoring from somewhere they've done a
great job defensively this year they've
always brought it defensively they're
tough they're physical uh you know they
are older team so a lot of times you
know there's a big difference between
somebody that's 23 24 versus a 19 year
old so they've been able to dominate
games that way
you guys had as Professionals in the NBA
what's what's advice you give
college guys that you know want to make
it even if you play overseas whatever it
may be g-league just getting to that
next level well I think the the biggest
thing is is to carry an attitude that's
going to be positive every day whether
you're playing not playing you're the
12th guy you're the sixth guy you're the
second guy being a good teammate is
something that you can control every day
whether you're making shots not making
shots and I think that that will
honestly in your pro career sure you
have to play well you have to be a
talented good player but that can take
you a long way as well I think that's
the biggest thing yeah it's great advice
I always say earn everything put the
work in if you want to be a great player
you got to have a good work ethic you
gotta have a great work ethic and too
many kids you know will watch clips of
highlights and expect us to do that
overnight
38-26 is your score we're just getting
underway in this second half got another
Yukon Alum here in the building
cron Butler here thanks so much for
joining us Ashley it's nice to meet you
I've heard so much about you how are we
feeling about this first half of UConn
basketball so far as long as we take
care of the basketball okay turnovers
have always got us in trouble in the
past as you guys know that and you know
if we just stick to the script no one
try to be a hero just get over the Hub
play the right way we win this game okay
we were talking to Renee to Kemba to
Jeremy Lamb just about how much things
have changed playing even when they were
playing when you were playing versus how
they're playing now what would you say
about that just how much the game of
basketball has changed how coaches are
with players how the situations are and
what it's like being a player Now versus
when you played well I'll say the
chemistry is obviously different
um you know it's more player driven but
I will say this the system is the same
we still run the wheel offense we still
you know share the ball we try to win as
a collective group and we hang our hat
on you know having a lunch pail
mentality
as well as we are really good
offensively we have to be really good
defensively we pride ourselves on
protecting the paint uh winning the 50
50 balls winning the multiple effort
game and that's that's huge for the
Yukon culture Ron you're a fan favorite
to a lot of people
I mean
your time at UConn what you've done in
the in what you did in the MBA you're a
favor to a lot of people and I think we
got some tweets that back it up as well
but how how much do fans
I mean just being in this building how
much are they coming up to you talking
about you know you're one of their
favorites whatever it may be
um some of the greats what is that like
to be a Yukon Alum you know what it's a
special feeling because you know I met
my wife at UConn right you know um she
was my tutor there we've been together
for 20 plus years and you know every
time I think about the University of
Connecticut I think about fond memories
on the court and off the court but I
don't get out much as an assistant coach
of the Miami Heat you know that culture
is different we actually have a game
tomorrow in Detroit but when I came
through this stadium and just seeing my
brothers I saw a rip I saw Ray I saw
Kimba I saw Jeremy Lamb Mecca ogre for
Kevin Freeman uh you know so many others
you know boom Josh Boone Ace like
everybody it was just like it was a a
homecoming it really was it was great
energy and you mentioned all those guys
we were talking about an all-time
starting five for the University of
Connecticut if we're if we're getting
your five who are you taking uh you know
when you think about UConn basketball
immediately you go to Jesus shuttleworth
so Ray Allen is obviously the all-time
you know goat for us
um and then you think about you know
more of an Innovative player of this
time you know who guys looked up to was
Kemba Walker now outside of that you
know any list outside of myself and rip
you know you're just looking at the game
prematurely that's how I look at it and
then you can throw anybody else on there
Daniel Marshall obviously with his uh
accolades and what he's done for our
organizations just second to none you
were on Jeremy land's top five so if I
mean if you had to pick who could you
fill out the rest of those four
you know uh Ray yep yep obviously rip
myself
and then you got to put Lionel Marshall
in there okay
you were doing TV and you were doing a
great job at it but then you talked
about you've gone back to Miami to be an
assistant coach
what was it that called you back to want
to change career paths there you know
what I always saw myself as you know a
mentor in that space and someone that
really wanted this to be in the battles
um instead of just like taking my
educated opinion of you know what I'm
seeing visually and talking about it you
know because you know I became a talking
head too much and I was like all right I
have so much more I still want to like
be present I want to be in these huddles
and I just want to move the needle and
other people process so you know um in
the summers in Los Angeles a lot of
players came to my house seeking
Financial advice you know just career
advice and things like that and I was
like you know what if the right
opportunity ever presented itself you
know not seeking it if it happened I
would probably pivot and it was only two
organizations that I would do that for I
was working with the Lakers that was one
that I would do it for but the Miami
Heat they drafted me
um I love the way that they go about
things Eric's supposed to reached out
who's been friend of mine for years
Player Development guy for me film room
guy when I was there as a player so uh
he reached out he said hey you want to
do this because we would love to have
you and I was just like hey I'm there
when you were doing TV did you ever hear
the saying you know you never lose when
you do television did anybody ever say
that to you you're undefeated unless you
just say something so you never win
either yeah yeah because that feeling is
one that you can't replace and I've
always thought that too like yeah all
right I don't miss the losing aspect of
it where you're gutted and you know
you're like man where do we go from here
but you don't get the Elation of of
winning either yeah you know what you
got to have some type of empathy too
when you sit in these seats because you
know you're always right right like what
whatever narrative that you create it's
it's your narrative you're right you can
support it with some you know supporting
details and objectives and that's just
what it is but it lives in a space where
you know it's not to be critiqued like
how you know players are immediately
after they make a bad decision on the
court or whatever the case may be so I
wanted to be in that space where I can
just really move the needle in their
process and I'm just glad that I pivoted
and made that decision Ron being on this
side of things now coaching in the NBA
what's some advice you tell guys that
are in this position playing college
basketball want to make it to the
professional level and have a good
career yeah you know what the biggest
thing I say to a lot of guys is this
stay present in the moment don't get too
high don't get too low this thing is a
journey it is a it is a marathon shout
out to nipsy hustle it is a marathon it
really is and you have to be committed
to that process you know um and I know
that now with social media and all these
different Avenues uh of streaming apps
and things like people are used to you
just microwavable success but it is a
process it is a grind how important was
Jim Calhoun in your life your college
coach he was everything you know uh me
and Coach actually talked uh today you
know via text I always try to reach out
to him and just pick his mind about
stuff I just saw his kids uh Jeff I saw
his grandchild grandchildren over there
as well so
um he's just been huge in my life one of
the reasons I went there is because he
had told me that I was going to be
family no matter what it wasn't just a
basketball decision it was a life
decision it was a lifelong marriage with
the University of Connecticut when I
went to
you're a favorite up here like we were
saying no disrespect to nobody who's
ever played but I definitely enjoyed
watching them get it done this is at
tough crowd I'm sure you're a hero to
many guys who who love college
basketball the game of basketball UConn
what do you think about this Yukon team
specifically how what is it about them
that's made them so dominant especially
in this tournament well I think that
they didn't Peak too early I remember a
game that we was playing the Boston
Celtics and I came down and watched them
while we was in Boston uh they was
playing Oklahoma State I think and I
came and watched them and they was
clicking on all cylinders about 12 games
into the season but then they hit like a
three-week skid where they were just
playing terribly you know everything was
just like going wrong for them you know
uh I guess they were sipping their own
Kool-Aid for a minute and uh you know
but long story short it's like they
didn't Peak too soon they went through
adversity they was told that they was
great best thing since sliced bread and
then they took they was told that they
was terrible for a long time and then
you know what they they took that and
then they had a reality check and then
they hit the ground running going into
the tournament and I don't think they
lost a game this season uh to a team
outside the Big East so that just speaks
volumes about this ball Club that's a
great point because you always want to
have your team peaking right before the
tournament and I think some people get
caught up in the early success and teams
starting to Peak in like November
December and then you're like come
tournament time and they're one and done
uh but I've got a question where would
this team rank among among the other
national championship teams at UConn
where would you put them what number is
this for us if we win this would be
fifth guys is fifth I will say fifth
is that because they're a four scene you
know what it's probably what is it the
lowest seed ever to possibly win I
thought the three was the lowest
probably win oh wait no because Kemba
them were three 2014 they were a seven
seed right I think 2014 was with all
right so whoever had the lowest seed
four or five
you put them right there
I love it what do you think about this
San Diego State team though the
Cinderella type story that they've been
able to have here you got to give them a
lot of credit you know uh just fighting
being consistent staying true to their
habits all throughout this journey uh
it's amazing to watch uh but I I just
hope that they luck ends here I hope
that everything just go bad for them
offensively I hope that they have
defensive glitches and I hope that they
fall short and we just like really just
catapult forward yeah I've always wanted
to ask you the NBA banned you from
chewing on straws that costs me a lot of
money how did that start sweet how did
you start doing that or why did you
start doing that my granddad used to fix
cars okay with a toothpick in his mouth
yeah okay so I always saw him with
something in his mouth and when I
started playing basketball that was just
a tribute to my granddad I was like I'm
gonna play with a straw in my mouth you
know then it became a habit a creature a
habit you know how it is you take Nancy
for your game you I had to have straws
you know that was just my thing I like
that cost me a lot of money in the game
it's like with Steph Curry in his
mouthpiece you see him messing with it
it becomes one of those things can you
imagine if the NBA told Steph Curry put
his mouthpiece in his mouth like keep it
in your mouth don't bite it though chew
it outside of your mouth wait I'm
fascinated though how long was the straw
like was McDonald's
were you particular like it had to be
McDonald's
straw I would have like one of the worst
games of my career
that's awesome throw my whole Rhythm off
if it were today's game it would be a
windy straw though right yeah yeah 100
well how did you get past it then I mean
if that because like I used to tape my
finger I cut my finger in my freshman
year really bad started shooting
shooting the ball really well and did it
into my pro career until it broke and
that was devastated so when they took
the straws away how did you kind of get
past that I still chewed them oh really
sneak it I just rolled it up and then
put it in my mouth instead of like
having it on display while I was
actually playing
wow and that cost me 2500 every game
yeah so that was like back in 2012 it
happened and our owner you know God
bless of Mark Cuban he said you know
what do not change anything yeah
continue to chew the straw they were
finding you the same as if you were
getting technicals yes or just chewing
on some straws Mark Cuban was a cereal
look he was so crazy about this he had
given everyone in the uh in the arena
straws so everyone has everybody yeah
yeah that was the third game yeah it was
crazy that is incredible
do you still chew straws today
absolutely okay I'm only not chewing it
because I'm on this interview okay that
could be your thing on TV if you go back
into the TV so don't stand out that
space Miami Sidelines you're two in a
straw yeah yeah always wow okay did you
guys have something like that only
taping my phone only the tape on the
finger okay no not not to that effect I
was a little superstitious but it's more
with like food and taking certain shots
before the game but never too oh I do
want to talk about the superstitious the
the pregame routine did you have a very
besides the straws but I had to take a
nap at a certain time I had to get up at
a certain time I had to be on the court
with my individual guy at a certain time
I had a special routine where I made 150
makes before I removed myself and went
and watched film and get ready for
pregame 150
minutes I've played I played with Kimba
in Charlotte he had a great work ethic
put a lot of work in a lot of individual
individual work Ray Allen the same thing
you go to the gym before the game the
NBA he was always there grinding it out
you the same thing is that like
something that Jim Calhoun taught you
guys or is it something that you guys
just did on your own I I'm curious you
know what they always told us that you
have to have a routine that everyone
else isn't doing that's what they taught
us at UConn like what are you doing that
they're not doing so Gino used to always
see me he'd be like tuck your shirt in
Michael Jordan always got his shirt
tucked in that was my thing you never
caught me with my shirt hanging out that
was a Geno Oriental thing in in the
hallways where he saw me he was like hey
tuck his shirt in and it always stuck
with me you know um you know Calhoun was
always just like look get up get a
routine as part of your pattern as part
of your algorithm or how you prepare for
everything prepare for success and
you'll be successful I like that and
that stuff really cool you played with
with Kobe what was the biggest thing you
took away from from that experience
habits this habits this always really
kind of the same theme same thing but to
a whole another level because you hear
about it but then you see it in real
time and it's totally different
I I mean I just read articles about what
Kobe was like yeah he was he was a he
was a hear about his routine the best
skills set you know uh individual that I
haven't seen you know summer workouts
crazy like I said a classic story that
uh I put out there a couple years ago
where we signed 130 plus million dollar
contract maxed out the first thing he
wanted to do was black out in his
workouts it was just it was just crazy
wow doing two days you know in the
summer you know 90 days out before uh
preseason it's crazy
has the league changed tremendously
since
I don't know even a decade ago it's a
lot of things you know it's low
management it's a lot of things that's
in the game that takes you away from
that
getting extreme with the hard work stuff
but you know it's a lot of things that
have remained the same as well
you got to play for so many good head
coaches and see that every day you know
whether it was Stan Van Gundy or Pat
Riley or some of the people you played
for Flip Saunders you know Eddie Jordan
who's your favorite guy you ever played
for you know what uh it's great you said
all those guys but without Max good it
wouldn't be none of those guys I
wouldn't be prepared for none of those
guys uh that was my coach at MCI Hall of
Fame coach uh one of the best coaches I
ever had in my life he was hard-nosed he
prepared me for everything that I was
gonna you know Embrace with all the
legends that you just mentioned you know
I wouldn't have been prepared for a gym
Calhoun if it wasn't for Max good I
wouldn't have been prepared for The
Godfather of the game uh Pat Riley if I
wasn't you know had that experience with
Coach Calhoun so it was just the timing
of you know the lateral coaches that I
had in my life it was perfect is it true
that Gene Katie did a good job
recruiting you to Purdue he did I I
already almost went to Purdue I
committed he did Robinson big dog he was
my favorite place oh it could have been
yeah
yeah I committed to Purdue University
Frank Hendricks yeah Frank yeah I
committed there that is insane yeah we
haven't been to the final four since
1980.
it was a done deal man that kills me
here you are
that's crazy that's crazy that's awesome
cost me a lot of money I want my money
back
I can't believe they were finding you
the same amount as if you were getting
technical files facts they was doing it
to me
oh my gosh that was wild I was shocked
when I got in the league and I found out
that it's 2500 bucks attack and if you
get ejected it's what is it 7 500 if you
get ejected well they got different
money now so it just went up a lot more
yeah
oh my gosh that's right this has been so
fun thank you so much for being here
with us it's talking all things the
straw thing I love it yeah catch you
with the straw all the time appreciate
you thank you again good luck to you
good luck
14 minutes almost yeah we're right there
we got we got to pull this thing away
all right you see what's happening here
they can't get over this 10-point hump
it seems like
35 47 just over under 14 here to go
I will give San Diego State Credit
because they are throwing some punches
here at UConn in the second half and and
what Quran kind of mentioned the
turnovers have kept them in it this
would be a huge shot if yukon's going a
little bit cold and San Diego State's
defense keeping them hanging around yeah
what they got to do is just find a way
to keep chipping chipping chipping away
because they're not going to get you
know a seven point bucket they're just
gonna have to find to get some easy ones
they just can't find some easy ones
they're actually doing a pretty good job
defensively and they're making the game
ugly they just need to find a way to get
some easy buckets
things even get out evening out a little
bit here in terms of the field goal
percentage Yukon shooting 46 percent now
um but like you said just turning up the
defense and that helps things
offensively too
and this is this is where they've shined
they come back second half deficits
um they do a little you know those
effort plays those going after 50 50
balls the deflections the little things
make a couple buckets this is still very
much a close game no absolutely yeah I
like what Caravan did right there in
transition put the onus on the officials
you've got San Diego State a little bit
off balance they're great in the half
court and they're in a trip to the foul
line like that a great way to kind of
break out of the scoring slump for the
Huskies oh now they're going to say it
was on the floor or maybe not well
they're very unsure right now whether he
was shooting or not Robbie last game you
look at the foul discrepancy right here
San Diego State has seven fouls UConn
only has three you know how college is
we're gonna see some touches come
evening out yeah San Diego State's gonna
get some touch fouls coming up it's
going to go their way so I expect some
calls against UConn coming up pretty
soon big Miss there on the front end of
the one on one that's that's I kind of
like the one-on-one because it does add
a different pressure That You Don't See
in pro basketball five fouls and two
shots
would you either one of you ever be a
ref no yeah I would really 100 oh yeah
you take that on absolutely college
basketball I love it and the thing is I
would the first person that gives me a
bad look starts back complaining no no
no no no no you let him go how would
Loki just keep calling back calls
when did I come just ask if I come
that's how I'm gonna call it give him
the business with the bad whistle the
bad looks but then the abuse that those
guys take you could not pay me enough
what's the benefit I mean you're
obviously I mean I think yeah for a lot
of those guys you know getting to be on
the court whether it's at the NBA level
or the college level you're with great
athletes you're a part of the game I
just think that between social media and
the actual stadiums themselves these
guys get beat on so bad it would be it'd
be a tough job but I respect the fact
that you'd be like you know what I would
do it I would take them on and I would
protect no one I know I wasn't expecting
I wasn't expecting that one of my
favorite teas is when Rashid ball she
remember when he stared down the road
and the guy's like whack boom bam and
he's like you're gone I love that I love
that clip and then Steve Smith's like he
didn't say anything to you he goes Steve
he was intimidating me he was staring me
down I told him not to do it and he
didn't stop and he ejected Rasheed that
is a great clip that's a great clip this
is BR final four live presented by
Wendy's we are man now under 13 minutes
left in this game before National
Championship is crowned a national
champions crown
we got more from the chat here at
Snapback said this is when San Diego
State's old age helps them out
experience matters would you agree with
that yeah I mean they're older than NBA
teams I think three of them I mean
they're starting fives are at least you
know that's that's pretty crazy so this
is where you dig deep and go to your
experience and you have older guys make
plays for you I think their oldest
player is actually 25.
[Applause]
is 25 but right now they need a miracle
they cannot score
I mean you can't come you can't come uh
back from UConn against UConn with this
big of a deficit I mean they need to
find scoring desperately I don't know
what it's going to take
it's getting very much out of hand a
little bit what do you know Jane lady
right jump hook that's what he's going
to do every time guarantee every time
spin go back to that right hook but also
I'm not even sure that's a foul that's
just good length by klingen uh but here
we go get to the foul line get an easy
bucket we'll see here's more about that
age The Experience from Tommy beer I
believe that says all five of
final four bound San Diego State
starters and all eight of their leading
scorers are 22 years of age or older
three of the Houston Rockets starters
are 21 years of age or younger the other
two starters are 22. I mean experience
does have to play somewhat of a factor
you see Oklahoma City Thunders
seriously wild so wild covet has made
this to where we've got so many old
players DeAndre Williams at Memphis is
26 and played in this NCAA tournament 26
years old there's guys that are like
seven years pro that leave when they're
18 out of college and have played in the
NBA for seven or eight years Lonnie
Walker was in here the other night and
he was like yeah I've been in the NBA
for five years I'm 24 now crazy and
we're just Stark Jones like what he's
already got his pension
24. oh my gosh that's crazy
but experience does play a big factor
and I think with the extra covered year
I think teams are looking at the portal
uh you know especially some teams that
can't get like a five-star recruit I
think the portals open up you know them
an opportunity to go get that experience
and or the coveted year uh having an
extra year has given San Diego State
obviously you know some help and it's
giving them an advantage to get to this
point and I think it gives us parity in
this tournament as long as we have the
coveted players because the talent level
is is bigger you've got older guys who
are experienced and good players and it
just think about adding another year of
talent into that mix it spreads out and
that's why we see some of these 15 seeds
or even a 16 seed Farley Dickinson I I
think it really does make this
tournament nuts and for the next two
years we'll see kind of the remnants of
that yeah and Drew Timmy can come back I
mean it seems like he's been in college
forever and you know what financially he
might make more money coming yeah he
could very well you know who knows what
his Pro crew will end up being but nio
wise he's as valuable as almost anybody
in the country it'll be it'll change
yeah it does it changes everything for
those big strike Jackson Davis comes
back this year for that Zach Edie might
come back next year Armando baycott yeah
great example he is back because
otherwise if he was getting paid he'd be
going whether it's overseas or whatever
to to start earning money maybe the
experience helps talk with the refs a
little bit we were talking about the
technical foul for talking that you were
talking about Tyler Rasheed we have it
right here oh yeah
oh this is one of the best oh
just for talking huh he was just he
wouldn't have been talking he was just
looking at him he's just staring at him
staring didn't even open his mouth yet
it's a great clip Chief was one of the
best yeah his technicals were hilarious
I remember when I first played against
Sheed uh he was with the Celtics and I
got in and he got he got a quick Tech
and I just started dying I mean it it's
great I mean the sheet Clips are amazing
how many he's I think he set the record
the one year with Tex in a season oh
yeah I was just like he was always
getting technical fouls he could not
help himself he couldn't it was amazing
now we have to talk about for the
Grizzlies Dylan Brooks that's his thing
this year too I mean
I know and Luca as well we the Hornets
we spend it for a game recently right
because he got he got they re they took
it out they rescinded so he's got one
more back yeah he's got one more I don't
know how fair that was it was the game
against the Hornet we saw the game
attack four what was he doing talking
crash or saying stuff to the rest to the
raft
I mean the refs take some serious abuse
from the players they do they take it
from certain ones but here's the clip
yeah there's Steve Smith right there
it's so good
oh I love that YouTube video
I actually like what Memphis is doing
this year there's been too much like
buddy buddy going on in the NBA and it's
good to see a team that's going to come
out and say Hey listen I'm not going to
be best friends with every team yeah and
I don't know if it's a good idea to be
an enemy to every team uh but I choose
to be taking that approach though right
I do like to see a rivalry and I like to
see you know guys kind of going at it
talking a little smack I think it adds a
little bit of extra drama and I'm there
for that I won't watch that I miss the
days of like the Knicks Bulls or the
Nixon heat yeah where there was fights
and they they didn't like each other it
makes for much more compelling
television and playoffs and I think it's
good for the game I agree with you the
western conference is wild right now it
is man it is it's crazy all right I
think Kemba made it on the Jumbotron
[Applause]
[Music]
Jeremy's having a great night oh yeah
and Kim is too but Jeremy really was I
mean just die hard Yukon fans same with
Purdue obviously I mean unc2 would you
say that it's die hard once you go there
especially yeah no players Purdue's fan
base is torture I mean we haven't been
to the final four since 1980 we lost to
a 16 seed this year
the year before so yes it's a tortured
kind of fan base even though we've had
teams that were capable of making deep
runs for whatever reason injuries bad
losses bad luck it has not happened
I will say I think Matt Painter is one
of the best coaches in college he's
obese and even though they they took
that big upset this year to Fairleigh
Dickinson I love the way he handled it
and answered every question after the
game most coaches wouldn't do that that
was really classy by him no he's owned
it for sure and I think that he'd
they'll keep grinding and if they keep
putting themselves in position and
finally a shot going down for San Diego
State but if they if you keep putting
yourself in the position of being a high
seed at one seed two seed three seed
mathematically eventually it's got a
break for you because they are doing
good things it's just for whatever
reason the last three years in the
tournament it's it's not gone our way
and nobody would have had Purdue number
one most of them if you told Purdue fans
sign up for the Big Ten Tournament
championship and regular season start of
the year they weren't even ranked yeah
and you just said yeah sign us up people
forget they lost Jayden Ivy top pick in
the NBA Trevor Williams yeah he was
really good good player uh they lost two
really good players Sasha stefanovich
was also a song government so they had
three guys that left and you know they
weren't expected to they they exceeded
expectations but then the expectations
ramped up for the tournament and that's
that's where it becomes disappointing do
they need to do something differently
Robbie to I mean to try and yeah I
thought I heard coach painter talking
about how they've got to get more
athletic okay for when you know you've
got Edie you're gonna play around him
with your Shooters but they've got to
get some guys when shots are going down
who will guard and who will get to the
rim and I think that's very valid well
they were filled with a bunch of young
guys as well you know their downfall has
been kind of their guard play if they
were going to show up in the tournament
if they struggled they're going to have
some issues uh but also I don't think
it's just on Purdue the whole Big Ten
outside you know izzo's done a lot of
work in the tournament but
a lot of people would say that the Big
Ten has struggled I would say that
that's not the fact and that's a fact I
would look at the Big Ten style of play
where if you look at the ACC they're
facing you know Syracuse's Zone okay
then you're having Virginia slow play
they get all these different looks in
conference play whereas the Big Ten
they're just a physical grinded out
style of plays all across the board and
it comes tournament time when they have
to prepare for a different style I think
it put makes them vulnerable I think as
well the lack of elite guards now Jayden
Ivey's he's an outlier he was with
Purdue last year he did not play well in
that upset by St Peters but when you
look at the elite guards in college
basketball I think a lot of them are in
the Big 12 the HC and even the Big East
you know you know the big big Ten's got
some good guards this year I think some
of the most dynamic guards in the league
were northwesterns and Michigan States
and look at Michigan state was knocking
on the door of going to the elite eight
you know they barely lose to Kansas
State
um but I don't think that we have maybe
the
Dynamic Elite guard play that those
other leagues have and that's what wins
in this tournament those guys that can
get their game on and end of the game
make plays in space yeah absolutely you
guys might have said this on Saturday
but just curious who you had on your
brackets
[Applause]
how many brackets I would say about four
but the one I went public with I had
UConn winning oh my gosh it looks it
looks like I'm uh it looks like I'm
gonna pull that one out but you know I
also I got four brackets
that's the one that counts uh but uh I
also had Alabama I didn't see Alabama
getting upset by San Diego State I think
I even had San Diego State maybe losing
to Charleston uh which it may take some
heat for but you know no one's bracket
at this point no look at this this is
it's saying right here 0.38 and how many
of those people reside in San Diego
county is the question I mean just past
two
yeah that is wild
I don't know I think San Diego State's
getting a little bit of momentum now
they're getting stops and they've made a
couple shots but but every time it seems
like they've made a shot UConn is
answering that lead hasn't been able to
I mean it's still 11. you know gotta get
stops hovering around 13-14 and we'll
see if San Diego's taking string those
stops together with some scores
I would go back I would put ladies at
this elbow and try to get him some
action with sunogo yeah we saw in the
first night he gets top of the key he's
going to look to drive
wow Keyshia Johnson oh let's go it's a
game big shot right there wait he had
three points and five rebounds
in the win against FAU only five points
against Creighton he's not a guy that
really shoots all that much only 22
percent from three on the year
7-0 run for San Diego State oh my gosh
to score make it 9-0
let's go unbelievable
oh that's a cool shot of their Arena
right there fans going wild this is
electric and you can hear San Diego
State right now this arena San Diego
State has just taken over
this is what you want a national
championship game to feel like no doubt
I mean we kind of had a snoozer for the
first 30 minutes but now uh now we're
awake
that's a big tipping right there yeah
that bucket went in huge push that was a
good tip in but this is what San Diego
State wants they won an ugly game they
won a rock fight they want it slow so
this is a game right now his favorite
ass
hello what up what are our locks at
right now Ashley had the 33 percent okay
I know 33.3 33.3 that's okay okay eight
point what was yours Tyler you had uh
you had the rebound good rebounds for
here we go okay Andre Jackson and cachet
Johnson I need I need a few more
rebounds from each other Andre Jackson
has yeah three rebounds
need three more Keyshawn Johnson
has three rebounds as well so he needs
one more means a couple more rebounds
there Ashley needs Yukon to win by six
they lead by eight and they are at 33.
looking pretty good right now we won
this one more Miss and no more shots
taken seven minutes
and I have for them to win by eight what
did we win did we get the frosties if
this happens or what I hope I hope we do
sunogo 15-7 so I need him to get okay
two more points and two more rebounds
he's got 15 and seven right now yes
[Applause]
you know that's very popular I've done
it before because
everybody says you should the salty
sweet I like it but
I'm more of a let me eat my fries with
ketchup and then I'll eat my Frosty
after oh you you dip this but I will eat
it I love it and I don't do it in with
any other Shake it's just the frosty uh
from Wendy's I don't know what it is but
I think that's a great combo my roommate
Frazier put me on that uh
right there you do it every time no
matter what
yeah if I'm going to Wendy's I'm getting
that Frosty I'm getting fries I'm a big
fan of the chicken nuggets I can't lie I
really like Wendy's chicken nuggets so I
I've never done the frosty with the uh
the fries really okay no no wow I've
tried it I would only go to Wendy's for
their Frosty because I just think I
think last last summer they brought out
the strawberry one or something it was
like a new change it up I wonder if they
still have it this year that one was
good yeah that was I like the chocolate
the OG chocolate Frost flavors are good
yeah you can't go wrong yeah oh the
fries are delicious Wendy's where it's
at
all right let's take a look I mean San
Diego State making it a game they're
down by eight right now plenty of time
left
it's hustle plays it's getting stopped
making shots like that that's getting
them back in this game yeah and that's
great awareness by that player he went
under the screen didn't get out and
contest so he knocked it down gave him a
wide open look and then they convert on
a fast break they finally they miss a
few of these in the first half went up
made the layup obviously that's an easy
bucket give and give him some confidence
I think also something to watch over the
last seven minutes here is going to be
turnovers UConn's got 11. and when
they've got loose of the ball San Diego
State's been able to take advantage of
that they haven't been great all year
taking care of it but with the
physicality you have got to secure the
basketball and be solid in every pass
you make get it to kashad Johnson
students 75 from the field I mean talk
about needing to make a bucket we got to
get it to the guy with the hot hand I
would definitely go to him uh I would
also look at medish if he can get him on
the elbow get some no go and some
Movement try to get him in some ball
screens that's what I would work with
Michael Johnson's leading them and
scoring is is pretty tied for the lead
scoring with tremel
efficient score yeah
how much are they feeding off this crowd
energy
I think this is like the the crowd turns
on the favorite there's a lot of San
Diego State people here but anyone
neutral wants the upset because that's
what human nature is so
anyone neutrals not rooting for the one
who's supposed to win they're not going
for the favor
I would love to see San Diego State win
yeah I mean even though we've had a lot
of Uconn people we've had to come
through here yeah we've turned on them
where's Kauai we've turned on the Yukon
people as well and the reason I say that
I'm not sure that San Diego State will
ever be in this position no that's true
I mean and that's what I think too yeah
and I feel like UConn will be here at
some point
this is a year there I mean you're
absolutely right when are they going to
be here like this again I hate that call
looking for a hold
right now don't hate me I dip my fries
into my No One's Gonna Hate you for that
it's the way to go maybe I need to like
really evaluate you did you gotta try it
we need that for this we have to go to
Wendy's after this
if San Diego State or or UConn wins
we're going to Wendy's how about that
yes it's a good deal and I'm getting a
Frosty and I'm gonna go with Tyler and
try to dip these fries but not the
chicken nuggets no the chicken nuggets
that's too much can't do that
Leslie Barry saying if you don't dip
your fries into your Frosty we can't be
friends
but like dipping it like ketchup like
everything how deep are you going like
there's a result in your fries you're
going a little like a little bit of it
or are you dipping the whole thing what
what is the what's the method to the
matter it would be I would say the same
way you do with ketchup I mean but then
there's salt in your Frosty right salt
okay yeah it's a great combo interesting
yeah so I wouldn't sleep on that yeah
you just you don't try you first of all
you're limited because it is a little
Frozen just trying to drag it in there
and then just eat it right there
boy sunogo really impacted that shot
right there right that might have been a
foul actually Butler got all the way to
the rim and 100 that was a foul yes yeah
letting them play
he turned on that ball screen and go
ahead oh
wow
there's those turnovers though most you
can turn the ball over that's quick
hands and and Butler that's defense
leading to offense that's a great play
yeah kind of like Robbie that's kind of
what you said in the first half
sometimes your best offense is your
defense and that's what they're doing
right now I mean they've had
back-to-back turnovers for Four Points
just now that Ball's got to go into snow
go there but the pressure on Caravan he
turned his back and he was not
comfortable
San Diego State the momentum is swinging
back to them down there too this is what
they do just chip away kind of like they
did against FAU and give themselves a
chance at the end of the game like you
talked about yes also they're
controlling the boards it seems like
they're getting more of those 50 50
balls which is a huge deal
actually you should have seen Tyler the
other night predicting these things to
Perfection he was like really San Diego
State needs to cut this lead to three at
this Mark and that's what happened a
little bit of that is luck because the
majority of the time I'm way off the
crystal ball
was on fire I mean just to watch it
through y'all's eyes because you you see
the game differently than I do just a
fan however may be
you guys see things that
have that you have that play your mind
I'm so short the high school career in
the interim Cobb County player of the
month County player of the month but top
counters in Georgia Georgia
all right Georgia who I was the center
really yeah oddly enough I mean I'm 510
but I feel like I'm not you know what
was your strong suit of your game the
drop step and I would I'd block shots
quite a bit right hook left hook
right right hook all right I tried to uh
you and Jane lady had similar games
right hook all day
oh man
five-point game five oh that's a big
shot right one guy you gotta go on yeah
he flies off those screens that's big
look at him on the Baseline now he's
getting all the way up he went from the
under the basket to the top of the key
also you can't go under that screen you
got to chase a shooter like him and also
if you get knocked down you got to talk
to your big to switch out yeah biggest
kind of see it the whole way stunt or
something oh turnover
that's on the big though to see that
actually he's going to see the whole
floor and if you see your guys torched
there's got to be communication but ah
it's good rebound by Bradley right there
Bradley's got six points here we go spin
right hook right hook up
Tyler I'm seeing you get real excited
how much do you just love good
basketball honestly get like this in a
high school I just won a good game and
I I want San Diego State to win now and
I came in here I wanted UConn to win the
reason all we've heard all night is
UConn UConn UConn we're so sick of it
now we want San Diego State no one gave
him a chance we just want to see a great
game
that's all I asked for a good game
I hope going for a foul
under four
wow
63-55 under four to go how the game when
you guys want it you guys killed
Michigan State right yeah we got out at
the inner fourth timeout U.S knew like
four national champs going into halftime
we knew it was over and also we beat
Michigan State
uh middle of the year we smacked them by
about 23. yeah we're a dominant team our
closest game was the second round
against LSU they had Marcus Thornton oh
yeah yeah yep so yeah we got off to a
big lead just thank you
in the situation there the pressure is
so crazy you know like you're as a coach
you're trying to keep your guys calm but
but you didn't feel that I guess you
knew the game was over well also you got
to think about we're in the final four
the previous year and we've gotten
smacked by Kansas sure so we all had
that memory and also I think getting out
and starting the way we did against
Kansas getting in such a big hole kind
of helped us for the following year but
that's a game where that helps you win
the next year absolutely that's one of
those lessons that you learn where it's
like all right we ran into this can and
can't it seems loaded oh yeah Chalmers
and and you know Darrell Arthur and uh
Cole Audrey actually Brandon Rush Ron
Collins rush they were really good but I
I've always thought that for any team
that makes noise in the NCAA tournament
you go like we played Duke my sophomore
year in the HD Big Ten challenge they
were a top five team we were a top seven
or eight team and they they killed us at
Purdue and it helped us the next year
when we were playing like a West
Virginia team that was a top five team
oh yeah and it just because we lost to
Duke we were able to beat the teams the
next year and that's a great example of
that at this level where you got to the
final four you get humbled a little bit
but then you you're like all right you
know that's that's what it takes to get
to this level that's an all-time great
team Mario Chalmers and those two that's
that helps you win the next year and
that's what's cool about keeping a group
together and we don't see that as much
anymore which is too bad absolutely
that's the one thing I don't like about
the portal is because you know sometimes
on some of these teams you would see
guys come in you'd have a course a
freshman you'd see them in their senior
year and you just feel connected they
felt connected and they represented that
school you don't see that much anymore
but back to your point about losing is
not always a bad thing I'm not a big fan
of the conference tournaments and I
never have been because I feel like it's
very difficult to win your conference
tournament then go on and have a big run
in the NCAA tournament you've just
played a lot of games fatigue standpoint
yeah you're fatigue you're also if you
lose you're looking at what you did
wrong so you're trying to regain see
what we can do to get right for the
tournament uh when we won it we lost
Florida State in our conference
tournament yep and uh it's rare that you
see a team win a conference tournament
then go on and win national championship
I just think it's it's too difficult by
the time you get to the championship
you're just yeah you look at the Big Ten
and acc's a Saturday no agency is a
Sunday final it used to be a Saturday
now it's Saturday the Big Ten is like
the last game and you wonder does that
negatively affect the league because if
you're playing the last day you have to
assume you're not
gaining much right the committee has
solidified what they're going to do yeah
they might have contingencies for team a
wins or Team B wins
but you're if you're a Thursday game and
you're playing Sunday afternoon late
yeah that's that's different than if
you're playing you know Thursday Friday
the rest is different it's it's
something the Big Ten fans I think
debate a lot
UConn's still up by eight but what are
they doing that's kind of unraveling
things a little bit besides I mean the
turnovers the turnovers are certainly
what it is they've had some tough misses
San Diego State's been able to get out
in transition Aztecs have made some
shots
I also think San Diego State's done a
good job controlling the boards that's
been a big difference uh and especially
with UConn's size and Sunoco and then
klingens been in there a little bit I
knew that was going to be a question
mark for him but also it's got to come
down to where they're going to get
Buckets are they going to keep relying
on their defense to provide them with
some layups that's a that's a real
question right now they need to get
stops desperately and then go back and
get some buckets to actually stay in the
game let's take a look a little bit
about what UConn is doing they got the
64 points right now man under feeling
title game
title game eight school to win first
five games of an NCAA tournament by 10 I
mean just dominating wins like we were
talking about when Renee was here sunogo
is one of three Big East players with
100 plus points 50 plus rebounds in a
single NCAA tournament he is a dominant
factor and I I'm assuming correct me if
I'm wrong he's going to be a key down
the stretch here yeah he will get the
ball now the question is will the guards
throw it into him they're gonna sets for
him but ball pressure can be a great
equalizer for good big it just makes it
so uncomfortable to throw the ball
inside
I actually think Jordan Hawkins would be
a guy that steps up he's an explosive
scorer he's hit some big shots in this
game uh I would watch out for him as
well because if he gets hot behind the
ark or makes some of these threes I
think he can put the game out of hand
for San Diego State give them the dagger
and they're going to run him off a
million screens here they always do
these walls for San Diego State they
were just killing them they haven't
scored in the last two minutes that's
kind of their deal they they go you
gotta change it for the championship
game they've got to figure out a way The
Times They really struggle to score and
that was great defense by San Diego
State just going straight up he just had
dropped coverage you could test the trip
to Newton layout but it is what it is
that's great offense
what do we got on the locks okay he shot
Johnson rebounds Andre Jackson rebounds
Johnson rebounds were at four
Jackson rebounds are at
three boy I need him to rebound he's got
to get like what he's got to get the
eight 100. he's got to get to seven
seven okay yikes my threes are 38 right
now oh but a Yukon brick just helps
oh Jordan Hawkins
went down hard
so what is Yukon from three right now 30
oh 35 you just need one more Miss okay
and what is this you guys have let's see
okay
15 points nine rebounds come on a little
bit is he going to the line is snowing
on the line here I think he is yes
it's five for six from the free throw
line cash out from the foul line here
this could be your big moment Robbie
this could be my big moment
the great the greatest moment of my lock
career 70s six percent free throw
shooter so more than likely he's gonna
be the final four MVP right yeah yeah I
got a question I see this in the NBA a
lot
technical free throws
when guys miss him do you need to
practice free throws with nobody on the
line is that a real thing why I never
thought it was that much different I
really didn't I know that I know that
guys miss them and they get
uncomfortable but I was always fine
shooting technical foul shots okay same
to you I I'm with I'm with Robbie on
this one I think it just comes down to
putting the work in shooting some free
throws I know it's not a sexy thing to
go in the gym and make 100 free throws
I'm old school I think the more you do
that the better you get
who taught you guys how to shoot
my high school this is pathetic is
legendary in the state of Indiana for
their excellent foul shooting and
there's a it's called The Virgil sweep
he was a great as a coach when my mom
went to Buffalo High School so in like
the 70s and 80s and he he had like a
20-step process and Volvo High School
led the country one year in an NBA
College High School in percentage from
the line wow well we got a random answer
a random fact too is Poplar Bluff
Missouri we have the winningest
winningest college coach uh or the
winningest coach in the nation and Gene
Bess so I was lucky enough to go to his
camps uh junior college Three Rivers
Community College I went to his
basketball camps he taught me how to
shoot so I was pretty lucky I love
hearing those kind of stories look at
that guys we're under the two minute
Mark here UConn doing what they do best
what does a fifth National Championship
mean for their school I mean it's
amazing I think it's what Tyler's talked
about this whole weekend they were but
yeah they are blue you win five national
titles in 23 years or 25 years that's
that's amazing and the fact that they're
undefeated and getting there it is so
hard to get to the final four it is so
hard to win national championships and
you've it's just amazing that every time
they've been to the national title game
on Monday night
they've won that that's crazy they are a
Blue Blood also you can say three titles
three different coaches that's a big
deal not many schools have done that so
it would definitely make them a blue
blood and also the thing about it is you
see all the former players come back and
it's all kind of like a family
atmosphere that's what you would look at
for all these you know Big Time College
Programs basketball programs as they all
feel connected and they all have that
culture seems like UConn has built that
as well I would definitely Place him in
a current Blue Blood situation
yukon's pretty good at Blue Blood you
might say is that a credit to the system
they have in place the multiple coaches
but still I mean
we we heard these hearing him talk about
how they're running some of the same
stuff that Calhoun did and I don't know
culture I think there's certainly a
culture but it's amazing because when
Danny Hurley took this job they were in
the American Conference and UConn was
certainly not the same now he's come out
and said had they stayed in the American
they still would have won but they just
they're a big East team yeah they belong
in the Big East conference and it's a
credit to the players in this coaching
staff they've gotten them back I mean
it's amazing
it's a good pass yeah the Big East isn't
the Big East with Yukon they they just
they just fit the Big East what they're
about
um
but also the thing about you know being
a blue blood is to me when you have a
program like that it's bigger than one
player it's bigger than one coach what
they built there is bigger than any one
person uh so it comes back to former
players all collectively and also the
coaches uh have you know all everyone's
had their chip in that program and and
built it to what it is today so you know
that's what I would consider like a blue
blood as well for San Diego State
when this minute 29 is up going back in
the locker room I mean they got to be
proud of the Season that they had it's
got to be something that we were talking
about before who knows when they're
going to be here again it's the same
thing though it's so hard to get here
yeah and for them to to make their first
final four and even the Mountain West
conference's First final four in that
League's history the way they won the
way they came back in Florida Atlantic
they beat a team in Alabama that that
everyone thought was really the it's the
betting favorite to to win the whole
thing the Creighton game was a total
grinded out deal I mean they have
nothing to be ashamed about you know
those kids are hurting because you you
want to be a national champion you want
to succeed when you make it to the
biggest stage but they have had an
unbelievable year they really have yeah
they have nothing to hang their head
about uh you know what they've done this
year uh you know they they will always
be remembered in tournament history hey
remember when San Diego State went to
the final four absolutely and they gave
that run almost had a chance at a
national championship so they should be
proud out of themselves and also Brian
dutcher's done a great job and that's
the one thing I don't like about some of
these Awards is they hand them out
before the tournament's over you can
make an argument he might be the coach
of the year totally I mean you bring San
Diego State to the national championship
game uh you've done all these great
things and it's almost the award has
already been given out and I just feel
like he didn't get the recognition he
probably deserves that's a great Point
that's a great point but the crazy thing
is is we base so much of the success of
the Season off these three weeks yeah so
why don't we wait I know let me wait for
that
wait a couple it does not make sense
who needs to change that who do we have
to call
bizarre of college hoops I don't know
who that is but that's who we need to
call
when you know it's the end of the game
like this minute 20 left
not likely that they're gonna make any
sort of comeback run
I mean just playing the right way to the
end I'm sure it's got to be
tough finishing it out run the clock out
well I need Andre Jackson to get some
rebounds yeah how many rebounds Johnson
to get some rebounds too so that's what
I'm looking for
Andre Jackson has three rebounds still
have three rebounds what's the no go
have 10 and 17 points 17. let's go oh
man he hit you're getting a Wendy's
frosty after the game you can just go to
the drive thru chains
one yeah
with all these free frosties and here
Tyler and are sitting on the couch
[Applause]
pocket he kept pulling them out he
probably had a couple more lepko thanks
a lot for nothing
[Applause]
so now goes seven another double double
for him man he has just been fantastic
this whole tournament yeah he's gonna be
the most outstanding player
get three oh wow and honestly for San
Diego State the core of this team lost a
heartbreaking game in Fort Worth last
year to Creighton so like Tyler was
talking about a learning experience that
that totally is you you build on that
you work towards something all year long
and it's things that you're going to
lose this but UConn has been the best
team over the last couple weeks they've
been phenomenal in this tournament yeah
David Dan Hurley's done a great job for
that he deserves a lot of credit as well
oh
crowd getting involved but we're not too
thrilled about the show out for UConn
fans huh the student sections
good the student section it's pretty 50
50. you just look at the colors yeah it
seems pretty good
well the fan section's got a little bit
more in there
wow some Yukon fans celebrating already
more than likely Jordan Hawkinson go on
to the NBA he's had a great a great year
for Uconn and really developed into an
NBA player I think klingon's going to be
interesting I I do is that's actually
one of our questions or does he make the
leap I mean I would think that there
would be NBA teams that would look at
the way he he moves I agree with his
footwork's gonna get better but the
physical tools that he has so somebody
take a shot at him at the first round
pick so the reason I think that he has a
shot is because I think he's going to
convince one team to take him in in like
the 20 to 30 range totally and the
reason I say that is because Walker
Kessler is who clinging kind of reminds
me of right now he's got that link he
doesn't have the athleticism that
Kessler has but if he develops his body
in his footwork and comes back to UConn
you're talking about maybe a potential
lottery pick so some teams could look at
him and say hey let's get him in the
mid-20s because if he develops we're not
going to have another shot at him yeah
well it probably depends on what he's
thinking too but I do think that he he
would be probably a player that's
looking like a first round pick honestly
like a like a Plumley brother or you
know Myers Leonard or some of those guys
that run the floor and
it is a weak draft too yeah it's a
weaker draft than normal
wow just looking at these highlights
from the last couple minutes the way
that they play together
knowing each other so well the chemistry
they have
nice share the Rock and they defend they
play the game the right way yeah and
that's what you want from your national
champion and that's that's what we've
gotten from this iteration of the Yukon
Huskies
lots of smiles lots of happy Yukon fans
to be counting down these final 30
seconds
for a crown and a winner
gotta make your free throws though
is there an uh announcer's curse there
is for sure they're showing Danny Hurley
on TV and he is going bonkers
[Applause]
his intensity is unmatched it always it
always is it's always there he's very
animated yeah 24 7. no matter I don't
think that turns off I think that it
stays
Yukon does it
wow what a run by San Diego State though
Yukon finishes it out
and the celebrations begin
it's Jonathan's on the court I saw him
do you do the slide he sliding the
second base
these are the moments that you know we
heard Kemba Jeremy Renee talk about the
the times you'll never forget this
celebration this night
you gotta tip your cap to what San Diego
State has done to
I remember after we won it my whole
family was there and I looked at my
brother and we were staying across the
street from Casino in Detroit it was
about after we'd celebrated with family
I looked at him I said listen my luck's
pretty good right now let's go to the
casino walked in there 100 right on on
the roulette table lost it another
hundred losses I said let's get let's
get out of here let's get out he's
exhausted
we've used it all that's a great story
guys this has been so fun I can't
believe we just watched whole national
championship game Yukon win 76-59
give us your final thoughts how this
game went as predicted yeah I think so
and it's very rare in college basketball
where the best team over the last three
weeks ends up winning this because of
the fact that it's a single elimination
high pressure deal it's not like Renee
was talking about WNBA NBA playoffs you
have a seven game series for a five game
series to prove yourself but it's been
very clear I think to everyone who
follows college basketball over these
last three weeks UConn was the best team
and they showed that tonight UConn was
much more dominant they've been more
dominant the whole tournament uh San
Diego State needed UConn to play bad for
them to have even have a chance to win
UConn came out and continued to play
dominant they didn't really have a
chance
Cinderella story for San Diego State
UConn dominating win like they've been
able to do all tournament long this is
uh be our final four live presented by
Wendy's we've got to think Wendy's for
all their love this set's great we love
Wendy's we're gonna go get Frosty dip
our fries in it the whole thing uh guys
this has been fun Robbie Hummel Tyler
Hans bro Ashley shamady thanks so much
for joining us we appreciate it and uh
here's to next year next next March
Madness
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]